ing your relationship in order to save.
Dude, it's such a bad hair.
No, no, no. Lay back. Lay back.
You want to twerk?
I want to twerk. I want to twerk.
Being like there is a fat woman who is like the most insane narcissist
and they have just been with her 24/7 for like the last week.
Well, we in the club.
It's getting worse, Cherry. I didn't think it would get worse.
It's getting
You ready for a little bit of a light-hearted switch up here?
I kind of wanted to watch this video a couple days ago when it
was posted. Never got a chance to watch it. Kidology video. Tik
Tok's obsessive boy mom. Okay, this is like a super overprotective
uh mom with a really inappropriate relationship with her kid.
Cherries. I think it'd be very funny. Oh, there are cherries
on her shirt.
RIP Salvation. We'll get Salvation back. Okay. I didn't mean
I didn't think he was going to I was like bullying him. I I didn't
think he'd take it. I didn't think it was that bad. But we we
love that guy and he's gone and we miss him now. Don't come back.
It'll only get worse. Moved up. Jesus Christ. Uh okay. Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu, we are on day six of Operation Rising
Lion. We began this campaign in order to remove two existential
threats to the state of Israel. The nuclear threat and ballistic
missile threat. We are advancing step by step to remove these
Oh God,
I sorry I don't care. Speak English. Speak English if you want
to propagandize me. Speak English. He he would have an English
version of that. I guys need a little light-heartedness. Okay.
Also, here's the Steve Bannon one that I wanted to watch. Donald
God. Unfortunately, we've got this one loaded up at some point.
I might watch this later, like way later. Okay. But right now,
little bit of a light-hearted fun romp through some Tik Tok drama,
some little Tik Tok story curated for us by Kidology. Okay. The
last one of these we watched was quite good. So, I'm looking
forward to this one as well. The one in the wife tubers. Very
cool stuff. All right. I'm going to get some water cuz I've already
finished all my water and get a drink, use the bathroom, and
I'm going to hit play and I'll be right back. Okay,
but I'm excited. Let's check it out. First prompt. I do not have
to explain myself to you guys. I'm so excited that this day is
finally here. Cannot wait for y'all to see my dress. I have been
planning this for a while. It's going to be like the perfect
mother son matching moment. Sometimes whenever um I don't have
any cash and I know that you have some in your room in your wallet,
I go in there and I get it. My dress is black and 's date dress
is red. I'm going to come snuggle with you. Okay. Yeah,
my baby boy. It really doesn't matter as long as thinks I look
beautiful. Don't he look cute carrying my purse? What a gentleman.
Y'all get to get ready with this crazy boy. They're back. The
toxic boy moms of Tik Tok are back, rebranded, repackaged, and
repurposed, ready to let loose their unbridled and passions for
their darling little boys onto the world. And in recent weeks,
one particular boy mom has gone absolutely viral. And diving
into her content and story has been it's been intriguing in seeing
how this boy mom is simultaneously trolling the internet and
is somehow still a boy mom. It's weird. It's frightening. It's
introspective. And I need to know your thoughts because the Lauren
Cameron Glass situation is a riot. Now, I don't have a father,
which is why I'm primed to one day project all my emotional needs
and trauma onto my son. But I pray that you all have fathers
and very healthy relationships with them. Apparently, Father's
Day is just around the corner. And one thing I always see the
dads at my gym wearing that I never understood were headphones.
So this Father's Day, as a bread winner to my cat and my partner's
dog, I got myself a pair of Raycon everyday headphones. Now Raycon's
everyday headphones are the perfect gift for your dad or for
you for every and any activity. I personally love wearing my
everyday headphones when I'm at the gym, step mastering it up
or when I'm reading and just need to zone out completely. And
that's why I appreciate Ray lies. What's up? She's lying. Those
headphones suck. Okay. All right. I wouldn't know. But wait,
why do they stop? People Johnny Bravo. Yes, this is Cherry. I
have been here this whole time. The do you mean is that Cherry?
I I don't know if he meant in the ad or Oh, no. No. Die. Okay.
He's just being racist. Okay. All right. Cool. All right. So,
this is about a boy mom. Okay. This is going to be disturbing
and intriguing at the same time. All right.
All right. Active noise cancellation. It is so rare to have such
effective and highquality noise cancelling functionality in a
pair of headphones, especially at the under $100 price point,
which is precisely what you're getting with Raycon. I cannot
hear anything around me bar my new favorite EP, which feels like
it's enveloping my entire environment. Personalizing my headphones
to balance sound makes them perfect for listening to classical
music. And when I'm listening to an audio book, I can easily
switch over to pure sound so I don't miss a single word. And
then when I'm at the gym working out and trying to get that adrenaline
rush, having my headphones on bass sound makes for the most bass
boosted gym experience ever. And this is all because of the headphone
360 personalized. Nobody say it. Do not say it. Do not say it.
I want to cover. I see you. Don't say it. Immersive surround
sound. And just like I love to fully immerse myself in my musical
experiences. Your daddies, sorry.
Trust me, daddy. Your fathers will love these headphones. Not
just for their premium features, 40hour battery life, a quick
charge function, awareness mode, the headphones ergonomic design
to make these babies wearable all day long, but also because
they are simply gorgeous. They look amazing on are fully adjustable
and are available in fun new colors to suit any taste. Raycon
start at half the price of other premium. I don't know why I
keep kept watching her advertisement when I actually came back.
I have no idea. Thank you so much to Raycon for sponsoring this
video and a heartfelt thank you as That was a very long ad read.
I didn't mean to sit on that whole watching and supporting my
content. So, I'm given these opportunities. I really, really
do appreciate it. Now, I just want to be clear from the get-
go. I like Lauren. She's spunky. She's funny. She's human. I
actually make sure that all the influences I cover I like or
find interesting because, well, you know, it makes my life easier.
And it also means I'm not going in with an immediate bias. Guns
blathing called out. I think why I like Lauren is because she's
a good example of a stay-at-home mom who's found an outlet in
content creation that she's clearly having fun with.
I can't afford it anyway. Hey, as long as she's having fun because
we love to see that. Now, on the surface, Lauren's content looks
very lifestylebased.
But as you scroll through her portfolio, you notice some things.
You notice that there's a teenage boy. Oh, her son is way older
than he should be. Uh oh. Uh oh. I thought I somehow when I was
hearing this or thinking about this concept, I thought it was
like a 10-year-old.
Uh oh, this is going to be awkward. Who's always got a camera
stuffed in his face? Let me see it a little better. Hold on.
Yes. Yes.
He's such a joy. Why didn't you get any length cut off the back?
You about got a rat tail.
Literally. You like it? I think we needed to cut the back a little
bit more.
Yes,
it's okay. But no,
business in the front, party in the back. And you realize that
because Lauren's
life revolves around this teenage boy, a lot of her content also
revolves around this teenage boy, her son. And because these
videos get Lauren the most views, these videos are what has ultimately
transformed Lauren into what can be called a boy mom influencer.
Now, Lauren's clearly been through a lot in her life. And this
is something I see a lot with stereotypical boy moms. Their sons
are their everything, not just because they're their flesh and
blood. Okay, I've got to listen. I'm trying not to make judgments.
I have to take this in for a little bit. Commentary is going
to be a little light off the bat, okay? I take this in and understand
what I'm looking at here. Also, Kidology is the person presenting
it. So, I'm not I'm not totally sure. I'm just I'm trying not
to call
I feel I feel very disconcerted. Okay. I feel like I'm at the
start of a horror movie right now. Like I' i've seen some flags.
I've seen some red flags, some some not green flags. Okay. I've
seen some stuff. I'm concerned, but I don't know what I'm looking
also because their sons were the only good thing that came out
of a bad relationship or the one good thing that came out of
a hard and difficult time in their life. I do also think that
boy moms get way more flak than their male equivalent because
of course women are blamed for everything wrong in society and
oh cry about it.
Okay. Are there a lot of uh dad daughters that are like borderline
eye their daughters at all times? Is this a thing on social media
that we just allow and it's awesome? I feel like that dynamic
gets called up by the cops instantly. What are we talking about?
Are you That's a thing in real life. That's like That's our congressmen,
our state senators. Okay. Yeah, but they don't do tech talks
about it. Okay. Yes. But they don't do Tik Toks about it. They
don't do content about it. Okay. That's the difference. Okay.
They keep that in their daughter's bedroom where God intended.
I'm so so sorry. I got to I got to chill. I got I got to back
all the way up. Okay. That's they keep it off of social media.
Okay, they keep it off of social media. That's what this woman
should do. So, in all of this, I do have a bit of a soft spot
for Lauren. And yet, I think what makes Lauren so controversial
is that she clickbait being a boy mom, but she is also genuinely
a boy mom and doesn't seem to realize it. Don't he look cute
carrying my purse? What a gentleman. I definitely just typed
in his birthday wrong. But Lauren is sort of like a new species
of boy mom that until now has gone pretty much under the radar
on the internet. But in order to wait, is Kadology Hold on. Codology
is like saying, "Oh, this person does satire on this genre."
Is kology just like too autistic to understand what's going on?
Cuz I haven't seen the mom do something like super weird yet.
I stand this new species. We need to touch on the rise and fall
of the original stereotypical boy mom. Now, the thing that I
find so interesting about Lauren is that I think she's sort of
becoming the face of the new era of Tik Tok boy moms. #boyom
influencers have basically deserted the internet on mass since
article after article haul them to shreds back in about mid 2023
to early 2024. And I would say that in 2025, there is nothing
worse for a mom on the internet than being branded a boy mom.
Well, maybe Karen is worse. But right now, the stereotype and
label of boy mom is something that I'm quite sure every new mother
dreads because of Okay, I will just say this could be true. I
have no idea. Kadology is the person who like navigates me through
this kind of trend. Cherry, do you have any idea what she's talking
about? Like this boy mom trend that happened. Would you know
any of the names? I've never heard the name before. I never heard
about people dreading being called one, but I do know this like
this is like an archetype that has existed and it's always been
cringe. Yes, this is true. The archetype's always existed. I
just never heard of like the Tik Tok like oh it went viral and
people were doing this for like content and to like make money
or something. Anyway, I think the the least strange version of
this is like wife gets widowed or divorced and then like her
son becomes her whole life.
Yeah. and then you just kind of pity her. But then there are
absolute versions where there is a husband and you're just like,
why is that mom so weird with her son?
Yep. Of its negative connotations and representation on social
media by former boy mom influences. But Lauren is quite different
to these now underground boy moms. So what makes Lauren different
to the boy moms who preceded her? Thirdly, as I said, most boy
moms have gone into hiding since late 2023. And most, if not
all of them were moms to boys that were under the age of 10.
I wonder if any other boy moms feel this way. When I found out
I was pregnant, I really wanted a girl. Like, see, this is way
less weird to me. If you're just obsessed with your like if you're
obsessed with your 5-year-old, that's like way way different
to me than being obsessed with your like like post adolescent
son. Okay, that's where gets weird to me. And I've seen some
weird memes on the internet. Yeah, I've just seen weird. I feel
like Okay. For I feel like that makes sense for me, but for people
like you and queen who feel like all women are You're supposed
to be concerned at any age. No, I don't think women are for like
5-year-old boys. Sorry.
I It's like It's like a way different thing. No, that's not that's
not when the child is like pre-teen
um teenager and the mom is obsessed. That is so weird. That is
so so so weird. It's like the It's like the the 13 to 16 age,
which is like a real concern. Okay, that's the danger zone. Especially
Especially when they get protective of their son having a girlfriend.
It's just like
that's your son, not your
whatever else. What are you doing? Why do you look so jealous?
Mhm. Really? But now that I have a son, I just want five more
sons. Like this is I want five more. My friend told me that.
By the way,
what is wrong with what this woman is saying? There's like nothing
wrong with at all. This is like a totally normal Tik Tok that
doesn't seem to fit a trend or is cringe at all. Isn't this just
normal? This is just a mom who is psych. They have a son. I don't
think that's normal. What is What is the face? Why are we getting
a face for this woman being like, I love my boy and I wish I
had more sons. I feel like everybody when they first have a baby,
um, they're like super
they can't imagine having five more. Isn't it supposed to be
really overwhelming? Of course, I wouldn't know. But I don't
know. I feel like I feel like this I've heard this sentiment
before. Every time my sister had a kid, she's always saying,
"God, no more. No more." Last time, all right, she has five kids.
No. Four. My bad. So she So she didn't mean it. So she said what?
What you said, but she thought what this woman thought. She said
every time she's like, "No more." Uhhuh. Well, yeah.
My friend told me, "You're not a mom until you're a boy, mom."
I cried when I found out that I was having a boy initially. Now
he's my best friend. I'm pregnant with a girl now, and I'm kind
of disappointed. Lol. I only wanted a girl because of the cute
clothes. My boys are so easy. My daughter is mentally draining,
and she's not even a teen yet. What the hell? Although Lauren
is a mom to two boys, she is primarily now known as the boy mom
to her eldest teenage son. So her son, rather than being a young
boy, is on the verge of manhood and is noticeably a very lovely,
down-to-earth teen, which adds a different element to things,
which we'll get into. And secondly, unlike most of the canceled
boy moms, Lauren doesn't have a daughter who she's constantly
comparing her son to. And this makes Oh,
that's what Top Bronson just said. Boy mommies use like the mother
version of Pikmi because the stereotype is that boy moms romanticize
sons over daughters. So if they're like focusing on their son
over their daughter, like to the detriment of their daughter,
I could see that being a big problem. I guess her content. I
get it. And far more palatable than other boy mom content. The
boy moms of 2023 had a near obsessive need to constantly compare
their love for their sons to their daughters. My boy moms feel
me on this, but my son has my heart. My heart and my soul. I
obviously am obsessed with Stevie Lee. She is the greatest little
girl in the world, but my whole life I always wanted to be a
boy mom. I love my four kids equally. But that last little boy
just hits different. He hits his sisters, he punches them. I'm
like, maybe he's having a heartache. So when I think about my
daughter though, that's funny. Missandra's blown the out. Okay.
Miss Andrew lost today. What's up? You go ahead, Cherry. Is Is
this like a mom feels in competition with the daughters, but
the son is no threat kind of thing? I don't know what it is.
I don't know what causes it, but I just think it's funny. This
one's funny. Okay. But I think this could be explained I not
for sure, but it could be explained by it just being her youngest.
Moms just love their youngest kid. Always. Well, not always,
but a lot of the time they do. Just getting married. I get excited,
right? Go out their dresses,
planning their weddings. When I think about my son's wedding,
I want to cry. Boys are the cutest. I love all my kids, but my
boys were so cute and adorable. Good, too. The girl was full
of drama from day one. Delightful. And thirdly, Lauren is also
a What's that? No, that that's just self-hate though. That's
like a womanhating mother.
Yeah, I think this is the this is the trend I know that would
uh fuel misandress everywhere. I know. Why? I know why Kidology
was following this trend, okay? She hates men and she she was
just all signed up for this just so it could fuel her, okay?
She wasn't signed up for like hatred of this. She was signed
up for all of these women and she would just watch and see. There's
something wrong with you if you're like a grown woman and you
just have like so much love and sympathy and empathy for little
boys, but not girls. What the is wrong with you? I want to say
that's wrong, but all evidence points to the contrary. So, a
Trump supporter I'm well is never going to beat me in November.
Donna's going to make the country better than you can remember.
Time to schedule nail day, hair day, you Ala runs, Starbucks,
eating out, vacations, grocery shopping, healing uh healing evil,
and living life a little more comfortably. Trump one. Oh, she's
dancing for Trump one. Damn
I didn't even hear that it was Trump singing Macarena there.
Oh my god, that's awesome. And I only say this because this attracts
a certain kind of primarily Caucasian female/mom audience who
at least based on what I can tell are okay we're just going to
take a jab at the whites then primarily Caucasian. You're not
less racist because you have a British accent.
you. And I only say this because this attracts a certain kind
of primarily Caucasian female/mom audience who, at least based
on what I can tell, let's be real, black moms are absolutely
at risk of being boy moms. Okay? Are we pretending we don't know
that stereotype exists from like all of popular media? What was
Kanye or sorry, what was what was uh DA? Okay, if not a boy mom.
All right, someone paid way too much attention to Kanye. You
tell me, Chatter. You tell me are Christian patriotic women who
are already predisposed to traditional men and boys are the breadwinning
head of the household value systems and I think because of all
these things Lauren has largely gone under the radar until now.
As I said though boy moms are a plague on Tik Tok. Most of them
have gone underground due to the excessive understandable backlash
they received back in 2023 to 2024. I'd say that the way they
communicate on Tik Tok nowadays is via blue hearts. You know,
you found a boy mom influencer and her legion of followers, if
she uses blue hearts and everyone in her comment section uses
them to say disturbing like this. And if you can't marry the
greatest man alive, birth him and raise him. It's so scary right
now. You know, I'm currently experiencing clinical depression.
And it's stuff like this that has the potential. Now, personally,
I do tend more than I probably should to sympathize with the
plight of the quintessential boy mom. And this is because I think
that her infatuation with her son or sons usually stems from
at least one of three places. Former rejection from a man, suffering,
or indoctrination. The indoctrin
uh the top two nation is pretty much just patriarchal male worship.
I see a lot of boy moms in particular cultures and communities
that make it loud and clear that boys are preferred, boys are
blessings, boys can do no real wrong. Not to say that this isn't
a universal phenomenon, however, because apparently moms that
have baby boys is because, wait for it, God wants them to experience
true love. The indoctrinated boy moms all tend to make Tik Toks
like this. They say when God gives you a son, it's because you
deserve to know what true love is. Oh, like this. Yeah, this
is No, no, no, no. This is the exact kind of one that I would
be. So,
this one you do have the disturbing feeling for. Okay, I'm sorry.
Do not go to the club with your son. Do not take videos with
at the club with your son. Okay. Do not take videos of you dancing
at the club with your son. Do not do this. This is weird. It's
always white moms, isn't it? Huh?
Hang it up, sis. All like this. Your
crying because my son is going to get married and move out. My
son is going to get married and move out and her son is a newborn.
Mariah Car's always That one's not that weird. Again, that's
not that weird. That's like That's not from a tangible place.
If you can get No, that is so Shut the That is so weird. her
her son was just born and she's crying cuz he's going to move
out and get married
in what 20 years. You don't even know. Look at how much of a
loser you are. Your son might be in your basement forever.
Can't kill yourself. Be my baby crying. The lyrics being, "You'll
always be part of me. I'm part of you indefinitely. Boy, don't
you know you can't escape me." I'm actually speechless. These
boy moms will also make it known that although they obviously
love all their children equally, there's just something something
different about their bond with their son. And it's always that
but which tells you everything you need to know about how devalued
their other children. Usually their daughters are relative to
the golden son who mind you is also going to be psychologically
damaged either because other women in his life. Do we know for
sure Jtock did move out? Do you think I scream the ed in a house
with my parents in it? No.
No, I do not. I do not do that. I rented a place of my own. Okay.
Maybe it's in my parents' backyard. Maybe it's an extended garage,
but it is a place of my own. Okay.
Will never live up to his mother's doting or because he's emotionally
shackled to her out of guilt. Mother and her son share a bond
that's truly one of a kind. It's not that she loves him more
than her other children. She loves them all the same. But with
him, that's the same mom who met her kid at the club. That mom
wants to her kid so badly.
There's something a little different. It's a closeness that's
hard to explain.
Like their hearts just naturally beat in sync. There's something
like this where the mom like runs over to her son after a football
game and like jumps up. Yes. Yes. That one's so bad. And he like
has to hold her up like it's a girlfriend or something. Creep.
Yeah. Like with her legs around him. And I'm just like, "Bro,
listen. Drop your mom, okay? Cuz that video is on the internet
forever. Don't let that happen to you again." That's up because
that dude's mom was hot. And like that's that's rough. Why would
you even I Dude, could I I couldn't imagine having a mom that's
hot. That would be so up. Okay. to be like a high school quarterback
and your mom goes and jumps on your hips and all your friends
are like, "Dude, your girlfriend's smoking." You're like, "That's
my mom." And then all of your friends are trying to bang your
mom and your mom's clearly into guys that age. That would be
up. Are you calling your mom ugly? She's not. No, she's not into
guys that age. She's into you.
This is the one. Oh, yeah. This is the one. She's like, "Yeah."
And she's wearing heels and she's wearing white jeans. you holding
your mom up like that in a strappy in a strappy top like a tube
top like that. It's not a tube top quite it's No, it's a tank
top. That's when the family has to come together. They have to
pull out this video. They have to sit the dad down be like you
are not paying attention to her. Okay. I don't remember what
this woman's face looks like. So don't judge me if she comes
down and it's not the way.
No, she is actually attractive. Yeah,
[__] up, dude. And she's got the pasties on cuz there's
no bra strap under that tank top.
Uh,
she's rubbing
full on. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. We're closing it.
I don't want to think about it. I don't want to think about it.
I'm feeling ill. Feeling ill. Naturally beat in sync. Okay. Why?
I'm just saying that mom is like dressed to the nines to like
watch her son play football.
Get the out of here. Uhhuh. Assad is bad. Thank you. Dude, that
got my mind off of it. Jesus Christ. Oh, sometimes they don't
even need to say anything. They just Yeah. You just hug each
other and look into each other's eyes. Yeah. Yeah. Just understand
each other. She would go to the moon and back for him without
thinking twice. Not because he's her favorite, but because their
connection is so strong. It's built on love, trust, and a feeling
of comfort that only they share.
Uh-huh. Little too much comfort. You should feel more uncomfortable
with each other. No matter how old he gets, you don't hug your
mom. Everybody hugs their mom. Slow motion like romantic music
of clips of you hugging your mom from your mom that she posts
on TikTok. That's too far. Okay, that's a little too far. You'll
always be her little boy and that bond will never break. This
particular boy mom has a daughter, by the way. He'll be his first
kiss, his first love, his first friend. You are his mom and he
is your whole world. Emotional
is not love. It's emotional abuse. Now, I think Lauren for dude,
yeah, I agree.
It is probably No, it is some type of um abuse to uh basically
treat your son like this and make him feel like it's normal for
a mom to have this intimate of a relationship with him. Very
weird. Weird to say the least. Okay. It's more into the categories
of a stereotypical boy mom who's a boy mom because of trauma
or suffering. Lauren was a single mother to her eldest son before
she met and married her now husband. And based on her Tik Toks
as a very very young single mother, she went through a lot and
her elder son was essentially her saving grace. So her boy mummificating
love for him stems from a place of him being the one constant
that has been with her through it all. And this all falls into
the realm of what is called emotional inshment. Now the boy moms
that we've seen are a perfect example of emotional inshment.
This is basically when the boundaries between two or more oh
I forgot this from Arrested Development. [__] people
usually family members are blurred or unhealthy. Family vloggers
are a perfect brilliant example of this. These are relationships
in which the independence, the privacy, the boundaries and the
individuality of children are clearly disrespected are secondary.
The children are obliged to be on camera. A lot of oversharing
happens on camera. There is a clear financial dependency between
the parents and their kids from a very early and young age, which
means that the kids agency is undervalued. Other examples include
if you have a parent who touches you excessively when you don't
want them to. When you feel pressured to spend your free time
with your parent out of guilt or obligation. When your parent
overshares personal details about themsel with you that should
be left to a or their significant other. If this happens then
you are very likely in an emotionally imshed relationship.
Okay. I'd rather watch brony cartoons while listening to Kanye's
Hal Hitler than whatever the this is. What are you doing to my
mind, dude? Okay, that first sentence isn't even fair cuz that's
just what you do on Friday night, Steven Jillian. But I understand
where you're coming from. This is a mind. All right, I hope that
nothing. Never mind. I'm going to hit play. Give me two seconds.
Oh, also I might need to Yeah, I do need to Jesus. Hold on. I
didn't Yeah. Uh maybe. Hold on. I need to look. Guys, I have
not shilled in the past 2 hours and I'm stupid for it. Okay,
guys. We made it. We made it this far. donate now to prove that
Jay- Sock is stupid. And I need to actually reset this because
we are 65. So, we are 10 13 subs. Technically 13 subs away. Now,
I could do less or if we get halfway, I could do uh the halfway
mark for 1 hour as well. We could be four subs away from another
hour on the stream. Okay, I waited too long to chill. Four subs
away from another hour on the stream. Okay. Uh we've got more
after this. I've got the whole Tom Foolery versus Dean thing.
I've got
Oh, I've got another thing, too. Tom Flurry versus Dean. We haven't
watched that Sam Hyde video from last week. There's also all
of the Chudlogic Tommy C stuff, which I might go through. I might
go through maybe.
Uh I was kind of thinking I'd wait for Tommy C to come out cuz
obviously it feels kind of like a waste if we just go through
the Chudlo Logic response to Tommy C and then we we we like evaluate
it knowing that Tommy C is going to come back on him and blow
him entirely out of the water. That's a little weird, right?
Like we know Tommy C is gonna totally dunk on Chud. So it feels
like we just wait for the Chud video. Sorry, the Tommy C video.
The Tommy C stream. But anyway, you ain't getting through all
that tonight. We won't get through all of it tonight unless you
guys keep donating.
Uh there's Overt Dummy with the four subs we needed for another
hour on the stream. Thank you very much, Overt Dummy. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Uh Tom is gonna be the next one, right?
I think it's Tom. No. Well, actually, hold on. Riyle Riyle just
said Tom Fery versus Dean is trash and you know I never don't
recommend Tom Foolery. So the Tom Tent might not be all that
good.
How familiar are you with Arrested Developments development?
I don't want to crash out on something that doesn't make you
chuckle. Um not super familiar. Tom's not good. Okay. Well, unfortunately
for you guys, I probably am going to watch it anyway. So, good
luck.
Good luck. Good luck. Good luck. I mean, how long does it even?
Uh, I have no idea. No clue. No earthly idea. Um, what am I looking
for here? Thank you very much for the Oh, to add another hour.
Yes. Sorry. We'll keep going with the video. We usually love
Tom 10 here. I think we can make it work. Okay, we might be able
to make it work. Does it suck cuz you got to take Tom's side?
Is that why it sucks? I feel like that's why people think with
your parent and I would definitely say that Lauren's mother son
relationship is one that displays characteristics of emotional
imshment as opposed to just being a close healthy relationship
because of one very important thing. It is very clear from many
of Lauren's Tik Toks that her son doesn't want to be on camera.
We have to go get his
baseball physical done today. Good luck at tryyous. Bye. Tell
him bye. I don't know who they are.
Note how he doesn't want to say bye. I don't know who they are.
Peace. Does it really feel I I don't know. I don't know who they
are. That is your son saying he does not want to be on camera
and yet clearly this is ignored. I
lunch time and we're going to wake. I need to see more. Get him.
Get him out. It's possible he doesn't want to be on camera, but
it's also possible that he just act like a mama's boy, right?
Yeah. There's like a lot of possibilities here. I don't think
I don't think that it's like he despises being on camera necessarily.
Okay. Well, I'd have to see him like actually get upset about
it. Women having an entirely wrong read of a man's emotions.
What else is new? What's up, BB Poison? How's it going? I mean,
there's also filming your kid in general for content is pretty
up because I don't think they understand the like what the internet
is going to be for the rest of their life. Like on that factor
alone, it's up. You don't really have to say, "Oh, look, he doesn't
want it." Like, he probably doesn't. What about filming your
life partner, Jerry? Which is what she's doing. Okay. E
I I honestly feel like that's not far from the psychological
process that's actually taking place. So, as gross as that feels,
I don't know that that's really wrong in any way. Okay.
I know that makes all of us feel a little uncomfortable, but
I do think that's probably how the mom sees it in some ways.
It's kind of up. Tell you the truth. Okay. Get ready for school.
Screw this school. Go on. Look at all this that you got beside
your bed. You got to clean this room today. Not your poor mom.
No, I ain't touching it. I'mma come snuggle with you. Okay.
No. Yeah. Don't do it. Baby boy, you got to wait till school
starts. Got to wake up. Can't be sleeping till lunch.
School cannot start back soon enough. She needs like a single
friend. Like one friend would have helped her stop doing this.
I Or a bigger dog to help you satisfy that issue. If you need
God, just anything but this.
Anything but this. Anything but this.
I'm saying anything but this. What are you saying? Anything but
this. It's got to wake up. Can't be sleeping till lunch. School
cannot start back soon enough. Teenagers and their attitude is
pure joy.
It's just pure dang joy, let me tell you. Oh, now I see why plant
dad said the thing about Hannah. That does sound like Hannah.
That is like the Hannah's accent right there.
That is a southern accent. I know, but it is the s It is the
southern accent.
Okay. I would have an attitude if someone stuck a camera in my
face to wake me up. If they judged my things on my bedside table
and were no doubt going to upload it to Tik Tok. This is oversharing.
This is an abusing animals is better than this at JStock. Yes,
that's what I just said. I didn't stutter. I wasn't confusing.
I was very clear. Yes, abuse a dog over doing this to your son.
Okay. Yes. You got to do what you got to do. That's a dog. A
dog is a lesser agency than a human being. Stop doing this to
your son. Okay. Yes. An invasion of privacy and a violation of
boundaries. And then you get into bed with him. Did he want you
in his bed? Did he want you in his bed filming it? This is emotional
inshment. In this Tik Tok, Lauren is complaining about her son's
music being too loud late at night. Now, obviously, there is
absolutely nothing wrong with entering your child's room to tell
them off about something like that, but there is something wrong
with filming it and putting it online, especially when he's halfdressed
and clearly doesn't want you to be there filming him. And by
the end of the TikTok, he actually throws an article of clothing
at her. And I get it. When your boundaries are violated over
and over again and words aren't doing it and you're a kid. Well,
we in the club.
It's getting worse. Cherry, I didn't think it would get worse.
It's getting
Bring it. And you're a kid. We're in the
Why are you trying to dance with your half-dressed son? Why are
you trying to grind on your son? Why are you trying to grind?
Like you're his girlfriend when he's made it clear. He wants
you to get off of him. It gets so much worse. Okay, hold on.
Give me two seconds. I have to go grab my phone. Me? This is
Oh, this is weird. Okay, I'm backing up just a little bit. I'll
be right back. You going to call your mom? Absolutely disgusting
comment from Cherry. I'm going to have to I will leave the Discord
if we get more comments like this. You okay? I'll be right back.
a when he's half-dressed and clearly doesn't want you to be there
filming him. And by the end of the Tik Tok, he actually throws
an article of clothing at her. And I get it. When your boundaries
are violated over and over again and words aren't doing it and
you're a kid, but we're in the club.
Why are you trying to dance with your half-dressed son like you're
his girlfriend when he's made it clear he wants you to get off
of him? Why? There's also been a whole series of Lauren's son
getting his teeth repaired after some rather severe damage and
we as viewers know about all of this because Lauren is emotionally
inshed with her son. This poor kid is semiconscious. What was
that? What was that? I missed it. I missed it.
My life may be stormy now, but it can't rain forever. This poor
kid is semiconscious in a car after his teeth have been knocked
to smitherines and you stuff a camera in his face. There is absolutely
no way on planet proof that he wants to be recorded at all. As
I said,
a whole theory. She's being soy. Okay. Literally, every parent
films their kid after they get their like wisdom teeth pulled
cuz they're on the drugs. And it is funny. Yes. And they say
goofy. And those are some of the best videos.
Where's the one of that white girl that start like twerking in
her mom's car? Hold on. I got to find it. That one's funny. Listen,
but she's a she's a risk, okay? With her son Loopy like this,
she's a risk. Her son just took medication that makes his memory
go fuzzy, okay? I did not trust her to be around him. Although,
I guess on the other hand, thank God it's on record. Thank God
it's being recorded. Okay, as long as she's doing things on video
camera, prevents some of the less savory things from happening.
Recording his hospital appointments. Lauren is always in the
surgery with him. melodramatic music about love and perseverance
is playing in the background to all these Tik Toks and her son
is just not amused. Now you know you're a boy mom when the only
footage you can get of your poor son is him walking away from
you or footage of him trying to sleep. Another thing that makes
Lauren a boy mom is how Okay, let me put this in language Codology
might understand. Her son is like all of your cats. Okay. Yes.
The only pictures you get with them where they like you are where
they're either sleeping or you're forcing them to interact with
you. Kidology. Okay. That her son is just like a cat for you.
Okay. Do you understand now? Well, she does that typical old
school boy mom thing of saying that she doesn't have a favorite.
That would mean I'm sorry if anybody in cat in chat owns cats.
Okay, child. But this one has grown up with me since I was 19
years old. Now, as soon as the butt is added, we know that everything
you've said is at the very least secondary to what you're about
to say. You're explaining why your elder son holds a special
or unique place for you that your youngest son can never live
up to. It's no surprise to me that a few years ago on Thanksgiving,
Lauren's youngest son said this. I don't want that. We're not
going to You don't want that, brother. No, it's not nice. It's
Thanksgiving.
We're supposed to be
She makes the self-deprecating cat joke. You're about to eat
that one. Okay. For our family.
I don't like him. I don't like you. I don't like you neither.
Okay, y'all. Quit fighting. It's Thanksgiving.
Oh my nicer brother. What do you mean? Why did she upload this?
This is maybe the least the most wholesome video on the channel.
Okay, that's funny. Two brothers fighting. The the big one picks
him up and like spins him around. That's funny. That's what he
said. He said the same thing about you. He said he want a nicer
brother. What are we going to do here? We're going to send him
back and I'm going to get another brother that's nicer to me.
I love how honest kids are. I remember
Okay, that's kidology being too autistic to understand like actual
human interaction. Okay. She thinks that she's like reading into
that. That's like a totally normal thing. That's a totally normal
thing brothers would get into. What the [__] are
we doing? Wait. Are you wearing a shirt with a mug shot of your
son on it? I'm curious as to whether Lauren made Are you Hold
on. I just wouldn't I just wouldn't have a picture with your
son's mug shot on it. Your teenage son while he sits next to
you and you go I remember being pregnant.
Oh, I remember I I just I I wearing this picture of my son on
my on my chest makes me think about being pregnant. Can you not?
Can you chill? shirt with a mug shot of your son on it. I'm curious
as to whether Lauren made him pose for that because in this situation,
I would actually find that worse than it being an actual mug
shot. I remember being pregnant and hearing the bond between
a mom and her son is something so special and I didn't understand
completely until Okay, I sent it to you. In the world did you
just link me? I don't like how this face looks already off the
bat. She's high on the Oh, okay. She's like Loopy from Wisdom
teeth. Yes. Thank god. Okay. Thank god that gash.
You like the song?
Is this your favorite song? It is.
Keep biting on it.
Yeah, I want the clean version only.
Okay, just relax. Just your favorite song. You have to stay here
safe.
No, no, no, no, no. You cannot do that. Lay back. Lay back.
You want to twerk? I wanted to work
on me
toilet paper.
Yeah, parents definitely need to record these moments. They do
need to record those moments without touching their kids. Okay,
thank you. That's all. She stopped her kid. She did stop her
kid. Kid crying. No petting. Okay, twerk. I want to twerk. She
was like actually emotionally devastated.
I want to ad
came into this world. It's truly so special and one you can't
fully explain. Blue heart. Did you see her fake when she handed
him the don't Oh my lord. Lauren son, I love that you are giving
us nothing. Don't give us anything. Keep it real. Keep your peace.
There is something that irks me so this is like actual parasociality
by the way. Like if you want if you want like an actual definition
of parasocial where like kidology is like I've totally diagnosed.
I know exactly what's going on in this mother son dynamic. I
can see it. There might there's a chance that it's just like
a a distant son who's like disconnected trying to be a cool kid
when the video is on when the the camera's on him. There's a
chance. It's not a high chance. Okay. There's something also
weird going on here. I'm just saying there's also chance. is
is the weird thing where Kidology wants to save this like 12-year-old
boy. That might be women on the internet. Listen, boy. Moms,
why is everyone obsessed with young boys? I don't know. Shar,
I don't get it. Top Bronson just linked me this for my son's
first prom. I'm so excited that this Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. This is later. This is the This is like the finale of the
We don't want to watch that yet. Okay, we don't want to watch
that yet. That's coming up. About parents filming their children.
especially when it is so blatantly clear that their children
don't want to be filmed, that their children are having a bad
day, are potentially going to be embarrassed by that footage
being online when they're older, are just not in the mood. But
in the social media zodgist, how it triumphs over the wishes
of our children, oh yes, it does. This is a violation of boundaries
that many online family vloggers and mom or dad fluencers see
as okay because of this pervasive idea that children because
they're not adults are not deserving of boundaries are not deserving
of a certain level of respect that adults are deserving of. And
Lauren exhibits this in what I also see as an explanation for
her being a boy mom. One explanation of stereotypical boy moms
behavior is that they turn to their sons for emotional support
due to a lack of it from their
Their sons essentially become the husbands, the supportive, loving
and emotionally available partner that the mother doesn't have.
And this can be in general or even in a certain thing like social
media content creation. Now Lauren's husband does not feature
on her Tik Tok. He is wait Lauren has a husband not at all interested
in the social media lifestyle that she's pursuing. I think the
only thing we know about him is that he doesn't want to live
in a liberal household when Lawrence stuffed her camera in his
face one time. What kind of liberal are you? Basically, her sons
were making on sticks that weren't sanitary and she went to her
husband
for validation. He was not interested. Cuz you make s'mores on
sticks. What do you mean sanitary? You put it in the fire, it's
sanitary. If I burn all the bacteria off of my stick, that's
a sanitary stick. Why are you pretending otherwise? Liberals
don't make schmores. We buy them pre-made. Who's got time? Okay.
Cringe. Cringe.
Seeding cool things like camping to the right-wing. Classic
loser liberal to build a whole environmentally hazardous fire
for some marshmallows. people are. Okay. Ah, that is a statement
and a half. Oh my, this person's a loser. This person's a perma
indoors loser. I'm just like blown away that they don't see my
husband on my TikTok 24/7. Um, but when I go live, so many people
ask this and most men that I know do not like as I'm sorry, I
just hear Hannah. Most man that I know. Most man that I know.
I'm I'm sorry, Anna. That's how you sound to me. Doing Tik Tok
videos with their wife daily. Now, if you do, that is fine. That
is a personal preference.
But my husband does not like social media. He does not like having
his picture taken. Period. It's like pulling teeth when we have
to take a picture. He does not want to. Um, and
People just can't seem to understand that. I find it really telling
that the adult in Lauren's life, her husband, has the autonomy
to say no, I don't want to be on camera. And his boundaries as
an adult are respected. Kids, however, don't have that autonomy
because even if they say no and go on with their day, mother,
sorry, I I would be very curious why as a family dynamic, the
son wouldn't go to the dad and say, "Hey, I don't want to be
in these videos. Isn't it weird that I get forced to be in these
videos? I can't imagine that dad allowing it to happen if he's
like picked himself off entirely. But maybe I'm crazy. I don't
know. Mother will do something like this.
She captioned this video, "You plus me against the world forever.
My first and favorite snuggle partner. I hope he always lets
me snuggle him."
Why the caption though? It makes it so much worse.
Come on, dude. Please stop.
Stop.
She's got to stop. Someone's got to stop it. Oh, don't say he's
your first and favorite snuggle partner.
No matter his age, Blue Hart, no. God, please. No. Yeah, that's
the appropriate reaction. No.
No. They ask you how you are and you just have to say that you're
fine. Your husband should be your first and favorite snuggle
partner. Am I wrong? Am I wrong? Am I wrong? Also, the song playing
in the background of this Tik Tok is George Michael's father
figure which features
iconic verses like that's all I wanted. Something special, something
sacred in your eyes for just one moment to be bold and naked
at your side as well as that's all I wanted. But sometimes love
can be mistaken for a crime. It's in your eyes, baby. And love
can't lie. No. Greet me with the eyes of a child. You can't make
this up. And this song, Father Figure, actually recently started
going viral on Tik Tok after it featured in one of the most memorable
scenes in the A24 hit film Baby Girl, which is about an older
woman who has a hot, steamy subdom affair with her younger male
intern. That's crazy. Maybe it's because I was That's That's
like the female version of the Zezy line. Damn. Wait, I've never
seen this movie. Fostered, adopted, and then fostered again.
Maybe like all the books tell me, I'm cold, distant, and unloving
because I never had a maternal or paternal bond. But I feel I
feel like something's a little bit wrong here. There is a lack
of boundaries that is so pulpable as well as Lauren clearly clearly
using her son for social media because in a way her husband isn't
interested. So her son's particularly her oldest son is fulfilling.
She kind of sounded like Cherry. Are you racist or is that true?
Racist or true? Racist or true? Racist or true?
That's crazy. Maybe it's
I don't know about that because I was fostered, adopted, and
then fostered again. Maybe, like all the books tell me, I'm cold,
distant, and unloving because I never had a maternal or paternal
bond. But I feel I feel like something's a little bit wrong here.
There is a lack of boundaries that is so pulpable, as well as
Lauren clearly clearly using her son for social media because
in a way her husband isn't interested. So, her sons, particularly
her oldest son, is fulfilling a role. You Oh, I just lost my
chat cuz Kick is having a great time. Can you make uh let's let
Kelly speak to Cherry speak if Kelly's in here. No, I can't do
that. I can't do that. You need to donate the right thing. Role
that he should not be fulfilling. Also, I don't know if I think
Cherry said be right back. So, she might not be back. And this
leads us to the major controversy. The viral moment that brought
Lauren and her son to the masses, generating a whooping 8.6
million views. Lauren would post what I will call promgate.
No. Why does she have such a [__] push-up bra on?
It may be his first prom, but I will always spin him around.
Now, this was immediately inferred as Lauren declaring that she
was going with her son to his Okay. Okay. How many chat messages
did you ignore saying, "Oh, wow. Cherry made a YouTube." What
do you mean? I didn't donate any of those or I didn't delete
any. Why would I delete them? Um, Cherry's had a YouTube for
a long time. What are you talking about? Prom, which in a sense
she was, as she'd explained. Y'all get to get ready with this
crazy boy mama today. I think that this is the first time on
this app that I am just at a loss for words. I don't know where
y'all are from, but down here where I live, parents get dressed
up in nice clothes and every parent goes to pre-prom pictures
with their child and their dad. Uh, that might not be weird.
Hold on.
That might not be weird. Okay. Oh, I heard it, too. No, I did
hear it. Hold on. Every parent goes
I heard it. Yes. But hold on. The pre-prompt pictures, if you
know you're going to get your kid in a like tuxedo for one of
the first times, like if you haven't done like funeral, uh, not
necessarily funerals, but like anytime in my life I had to get
dressed up for stuff. I feel like my my parents always wanted
to do um like family photos and [__] right? Somebody's
getting dressed up. Oh, well, I'll do family photos. I don't
think this is that weird. I think if she started talking about
going to prom with them, that is very odd. Lost for words. I
don't know where y'all are from, but down here where I live,
parents get dressed up in nice clothes and every parent goes
to pre-p prom. Oh, you hear pictures with their child and their
date
and they take pictures of their kids and then they have a very
nice sit down dinner where the parents are still there. Prom
dresses where I'm from do not look like the dress that I had
on. They are very much so formal, sparkly. What I had to say,
why is there a poll that says, "Does Kidology sound like Cherry?"
"No." "Are you slow?" Why did that even need to be a poll? I
don't know who made that poll, but it was about a different sound
clip that sounded like you. So, that poll wasn't even correct.
I did see the numerous chats that are like, "Oh, when did Jerry
make a YouTube channel?" This is Kidology. And there was a time
in my life where I wore like fake bangs to Yeah, I understand.
I I get what you see. Um but no, we don't look alike. No, I I
don't want to even talk. Yeah, I'm going to move forward just
entirely.
There's nothing I can say. You guys don't look alike.
I have real bangs, but I also had fake bangs. Okay, I've been
hit by I also had a blonde wig. That was pretty cool. Okay, that
does sound cool. You could be like the Aryan AOC. You could get
blue contacts and then wear the blonde wig and you could be like
the Aryan AOC pictures.
Be like the same thing. I did make that AOC dress. You like the
cursed version. You did. That's true. I still have it. It says
tax the poor. Tax the poor. unrest. However, even if Lauren was
going in a parental capacity, people were primarily concerned
with how obviously uncomfortable her son looked in the Tik Tok,
particularly because this particular Tik Tok is a prom date trend.
So, basically, prom date transitions were trending because it's
currently prom season. And essentially, prom dates do a quirky,
cute little video together. Emphasis on the prom dates. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What the positions
were trending because it's currently prom season and that guy
is tiny. Is that a gay? That's a woman, right? Who spins him?
This is This guy is like This guy is a full like a full hand
shorter than his prom date. Actually, prom dates do a quirky
cute little video. No, no, they're both guys. Never mind. They're
both emphasis on they're just gay. They're just gay. The prom
date. So Lauren as a mother had to get onto that trend. Had to
get onto that. Just gay. They're just gay.
Paige. So this this happened. Here is the reality of that video.
I didn't have anything scheduled to post for that day and I didn't
have time to edit a video or anything. So I needed to do something
quick and fun and cute. The transition that we did, it is not
a prom transition. Okay? If you want to tell yourself that, then
go right ahead. Maybe it was the song, but I just found a trending
sound. I'm not on the prom for you page. So, I was like, "Okay,
wait, did they play the whole thing?" They do. Uh, are we going
to watch it again? Okay, we do see the whole thing. Because if
you've been following me, then you know that I have done that
transition several times before. My cousin's wedding just two
months ago did the same thing, put a different sound to it. So,
I was like, "We're going to do this today." He was all aboard.
Honestly, it was just for me to document his first prom. No attachment
issues. Want him to have a girlfriend? No attachment. Stop. Did
someone say attachment issues? No. No. Want him to not have a
wife? If you want me to be real with you, I'm one bad ass boy
mom and going to be one hell of a mother-in-law. Ignorance. Pretty
much sums it up. If anything, you should have really watched
that video and been like, "This is a mom who loves her child."
as a content creat. Listen, listen here. I don't want to my son
at all. I don't want to [__] him at all. Actually,
you're just ignorant. It's ignorance.
On this app, we make get ready with me. We make transition. I
was dressed up in a dress because if you go through all my other
videos, I dress up almost every single day. We had pictures and
they had dinner before prom. So, it was just an easy little video.
I would eat before there's supposed to be food served at prom.
Really? Yeah. My prom had a half the money that we uh raised
for prom was for the catering cuz we wanted to get like really
good food. Oh wow. Myself to you guys. But this just makes it
a little bit more clear for you. So that you feel just like probably
this big. Maybe not because you're probably lacking what Oh no.
J didn't go to prom. Why do you think I graduated high school?
One of these. Oh yes. And another stereotypical boy mom characteristic
is to deny, deny, deny that anything you do could be potentially
harmful to your son. Sad thing is she'll read all these comments
and still think she did nothing wrong. Accurate. Oh, Lauren.
And thus, we were graced with this very mature. I have a college
degree. I do not have a high school diploma.
Introspective response.
four. I don't know why, but my my um my prom it was like a kinetta.
There was a dinner, there was a whole dinner, there was ourbs
in the beginning. Um and then there was like a live performance
and then everybody got to dance and stuff and then there was
like a big dessert thing with cake and stuff like that. Wow.
Sounds like some great memories that I totally share and can
commiserate on, you know. Cool. Prom was awesome. Love to see
it. I'm going to hit play. first prom. Wait, wait, wait. This
is this is the actual uh this is the actual Tik Tok that spawned
the controversy for an introspective coming up next. Get ready
with me for my son's first
excited that this date is finally here. Cannot wait for y'all
to see my dress. I have been planning this for a while. It is
so cute. It's going to be like the perfect mother son matching
moment. I didn't have time to get my hair and makeup done like
all the other girls. Um so I hope that my makeup Why are you
comparing yourself to the other girls? My hair turns out good.
I have to help get ready. It really doesn't matter as long as
she's going to be in competition with those girls for the rest
of her life. Apparently my dress is black and date dress is red.
I can't wait to show y'all. My son My dress is black and my son's
date dress is red. Uhhuh. Flowers that I ordered for myself for
to give me. They are so pretty. I really hope someone's going
to be there so they can capture that moment cuz it is going to
be so cute. Ordering your own flowers that your son is going
to give you. Could you Wait, wait, wait. Could you imagine if
she ordered a cor
party theme is Y2K? Right up my alley. Now that my makeup is
done, I am going to put on my dress. Here is the final look.
Here is my dress. My flowers.
Am I the only one who would I like just for me personally and
maybe I have issues. Okay. I don't know that I'd be feel comfortable
like my mom being super close to me wearing that dress like like
spinning me around and I would not feel comfortable taking like
super close prom pictures where we're doing like dance moves
and I'm sorry it would feel weird. It would just feel weird.
Dumb thick from the waist down. Her thighs are huge.
Like in a positive way. Uh-huh. That's pretty crazy. That's pretty
crazy. So pretty. I love this dress. I got it from the thrift
store for $4. My earrings are from Exp. Okay, that's
$4. That's normally how much it costs when you get get it thrifted.
Okay. Uh we got some really really weird people in the I don't
even know what this poll is. Who made this poll and why? But
I love you for making it cuz it's weird and it's just highlighting
the weirdness. But why can I hear Wes saying the last option?
Oh, it's Sophia. Oh, thank you, Sophia. I thought Sorry. Ouch
you, Sophia.
Oh, you said you made it. Okay, thank God. Uh, this dress is
crazy for a mom to her son's prom. Well, that's what I thought.
Okay, that's very
like objectively, if you're the son, why would you want your
mom looking like that being around all your friends, right? That
would be weird. That would be weird.
That would be so weird.
JNX
I like my entire closet is thrifted. I think I only thrift shop.
She's planning to find someone to rail. Like duh. Maybe her son.
Maybe her son's best friend. Hard to say. It's from the golden
hanger. My flowers. They are from and I did get a bootineer.
And his date also got him one. We'll see which one he likes better.
Now it's time. No.
Stop. Go take pictures. Stop competing. Stop competing. Stop
competing. Stop competing.
Love you guys. Lauren then showed us her various prom. Oh, why
did she have so dress options? Because people were apparently
calling the original sundress a prom dress and that apparently
had to be corrected. Since y'all are just so confused on prom
and what a prom dress is, let me just help you out a little bit.
She then went into full rage bait mode which involved many things
including for reasons unbeknownst to me a wheelchair. I can't
even remotely predict how that comes up. She hold cosplay. I
get it. I see it. Black face. This feels racist.
It's weird. Very red lips. What the [__] is What
is happening? What is occurring? Racism. What is occurring on
my screen? Why do I feel like a man right there? I don't know.
She suddenly has a job man in makeup. She got an Adam's apple.
What happened? What is happening? She then got into a Please,
for the love of Could you imagine? I I had a premonition just
now. Do we see the the son's date? And is the son's date in a
wheelchair? Okay, cuz that actually explains everything perfectly.
I'd be so disturbed. Little bit of beef with a famous Tik Tocker
called Aunt Karen after Aunt Karen made this video paring Lauren.
Those of you who know me know what it looks like for me to crash
out. Like Lauren, because she doesn't care about the haters,
responded in what appears to be a now deleted comment saying
that on Karen was just trying to gain views off of her content.
Well, me too, Lauren. Girl, come on. Get up off of it. You made
a video. You went viral. People thought it was funny. People
thought it was creepy. People thought it was weird. They have
their opinions. You're not the first person to make a video.
and and garner a ton of views off of it. You won't be the last.
Let me tell you, I'm not the one, the two, or the three. I've
made plenty of opinions. People didn't like, people did like.
And you coming to me trying to act like I'm just riding you for
clout. Let me tell you, if you're a bull, I'm on top of it. Yeah.
So, I want That's I got Corantos energy from that. You know what
I'm saying? You know what I'm saying? He always used to say that.
watched all of this playing out chronologically from the original
video to the prom video to the response videos to the rage bait
videos to the satirical response videos. It's my baby's wedding
day. Now we don't got folks calling us ancestrial and all. And
this is what I believe happened. I believe that the original
prom video was genuine. In Lauren's mind, it was a super cute
boy mom prom experience personified that was deemed harmless
because apparently this is what happens where she's from. These
boy moms aren't just happy with Mother's Day. Oh no, they now
need prom day. I think what then happened is Lauren saw the backlash
and did what every good and well-trained influencer does, satarize,
deny, disengage. You don't respond seriously to comments calling
you out. Instead, you make follow-up videos overexaggerating
that which initially got you called out for because then everybody
thinks, "Ha, it was all a joke. She's just a funlov and satirical
mommy vlogger." So now when Lauren posts this Tik Tok, people
think this is satire. A mother is her son's first love and he
is her forever hero.
O
yikes, that is some major snaggle tooth. Unlucky. Oh, his face
definitely looks like his mother is his first love. And you see,
I would have thought that this was a part of the rage baiting
satirical
genetics are not great there. Okay, what's up?
Maybe he does love his mom. What does this kidology know? I think
he probably loves his mom. I think I think he could easily like
make those not work at all. Right. I think he probably to some
extent is like fine with her doing that. I don't know. It's like
a It's almost certainly a dynamic, but like the idea that he
just refuses he really would honestly if he had the choice refuse
all participation. I don't think that's true. Crash out. But
considering that we got gems like this and this and this and
this. That just looked like he was having fun, right? And you
see I like I'm sorry, but right here he's smiling and laughing
while she gets while he twirls. Well, she What?
You don't understand. Kidology can see how tormented he is right
now. He needs saving.
Yeah, I feel like she pulled a couple where he looks unhappy
and he's like, "Yeah, I don't know." Anyway, to one who to the
one who made me a mom first and changed my life at a young age.
I Okay, I pray we always have this bond. He didn't make you a
mom. Stop
fantasizing about him making you a mom. Okay. He didn't make
you a mom. That was your husband.
That was your husband.
like this and this and this and this way back before promgate.
I'm not so sure that this really is satire, brethren. Do any
of you wrap your thigh around your sleeping son? Film it and
upload it to Tik Tok. Do any of you spot your teenage sons like
this?
Okay. No. Okay. She's like so she's like 3 years away from
being a Thor. Okay. Never mind.
Lock her up. Lock her up.
No. Stop.
Stop. I was kind of defending you. Stop. And I know. I know it's
a joke, but why is it this kind of joke at his expense? And this
is the thing. This is the thing that Lauren doesn't seem to understand.
The thing that Lauren doesn't seem to understand is that even
though all of these videos, including the original ones, may
have been satire, she, whether inest or not, turned her son's
prom into a prom about her. This original prom video generated
nearly 9 million views. This one generated nearly 7 million views.
The only thing they're talking about at school, in your community,
everywhere online, is about how you, Lauren, dressed up for your
son's prom, made a Tik Tok with the title, "It may be his first
prom, but I'll always spin him around." Even if it was just for
a Tik Tok, his prom and all the good nostalgic memories that
are meant to come with that experience will forever be associated
with this viral moment that is all about you. And it's obviously
done harm because he's now had to private his TikTok. And what
is just as sad is that his prom's date will forever be associated
with you and this situation. Imagine being his date. And this
is what you're going to remember about what is meant to be every
teenager's magical night. Her not being able to see that really
shows me how I mean, I hope that his prom date wasn't thing about
his mom's TikTok.
I just I hope they had better things going on. emotionally in
mesh she is with her son in my opinion that this hasn't even
crossed her mind is concerning but as I said I do believe she
means well but don't they all please let me know your thoughts
I would especially love to know whether any of you have a stereotypical
boy mom in your life are any of you not stereotypical boy moms
but just boy moms and what do you think of these stereotypical
boy moms my biggest fear is that one day I will join the blue
heart brigade
I want out of this timeline thank Thank you so so very very much
for watching, brethren, and I'll see all of you very very soon
in the next one. So, here's my hat and her paws are Jesus. What
is happening? The paws have paws.
Oh no, that's horrifying. Apparently, yesterday there's a lot
of um reportings that the the jurors for the Diddy trial were
forced to watch uh clips of the freakoff tapes. Awesome. I'm
trying to see if I can get some of the recordings because, you
know, we don't get like any uh recordings or videos of what's
going on in the trial. So, it's just going to be reporters taking
notes and stuff. Um,
I hate to say I hate to just click on another Kidology video,
but YouTube's most hated age gap influencer, Julia
a 66-year-old woman and then a 60-year-old man. I
am almost here for it. Okay, we could do this or Tom. And I'm
feeling like this is the better option than Tom right now, but
maybe I'm crazy. I'm willing to give it a shot at least. Okay,
600,000 views a month ago. I didn't see this. Let's see here.
Let me take a look around. I don't know what else is going on
right now, but uh Oh, is is Twitch is Kick having issues? If
you want, guys, like here, apparently Kick's having major issues.
I'll go live on Twitch if you guys are really having like major
issues. if you can't view tonight. Some people are some people
are telling me that don't go to Twitch. They don't usually, but
they might right now. Apparently the the kick is like actually
messed up right now. Okay, I'm going to read this reporting.
You can go live on Twitch. Yeah, I'm going to fire up the Twitch.
Okay. The jury at Diddy's trial had a horrifying reaction to
being shown videos in court yesterday, but not yesterday. It's
on the 16th. For the first time, six weeks into the 8-week trial,
jurors were shown tapes from the drugfueled freakoffs. Uh, the
rapper allegedly orchestrated as Shawn Diddy Combmes faces charges
for racketeering, trafficking, and transportation
uh to engage in prostitution.
Uh, the court has previously heard audio recordings and seen
still images of these days long marathons. Oh, I guess this is
the first time that they actually watch videos. So, they've only
heard audio recordings. They've only seen photos
so far in the 6 weeks. His ex-girlfriend Cassie previously shared
shocking details of freakoffs with the jurors having intensely
heard about the encounters over the weeks. Prosecutors played
clips from three videos with only the jury, judge, witness, and
parties a um able to view. Okay. Uh the defense team were not
shown these videos as their monitors could be seen by members
of the public and press having spent the past few weeks hearing
details about the freakoffs such as Cassie's feelings towards
them as it's buying baby oil and lube and how they were filmed.
It's reported that the jurors seemed almost desensifi desensitized
yesterday. Three videos were shown were created in October 2012,
2014 and December 2014.
While one video was over half an hour long, the clips the jury
was were shown totaled to just over two minutes. What? Oh, so
they only saw 2 minutes of the whatever like 2our long break
clips of it. Okay. Just faces maybe just to prove people were
there. I'm not even totally sure. The the jury were shown a a
number of texts between Cassie and Diddy setting up freakoffs.
Cassie previously told the court that she hated doing these.
Okay. Yeah, I saw that. Um Okay. All right. That's it. That's
all I got.
But
yeah, I guess no details. I kind of need details on the freakoff
stuff, right? Just like telling us that they happened. They got
clips. I'm sure we'll see more though. I'm sure we'll see some
stuff. Is a freakoff like a danceoff? Kind of. Except you get
drugged and then you get But other than that, it's exactly like
a danceoff.
pretty close in fact. Yeah, basically the same thing. Okay guys,
we're live on Twitch. If you have issues on Kick, if you have
issues typing on Kick or whatever, we're live on Twitch. Uh I
can't even shut multireaming off or I can't turn multireaming
back on. Um I'll wait until Kick messages me and I'll say like,
"Hey, it won't go back on. Uh your site's messed up right now."
Okay, are we ready? YouTube's most hated age gap influencer.
I just feel like I'm good for another kidology video right now.
Also, fun fun thing to anticipate. Okay. Will Kadalji be more
upset about the male or female age gap relationship here? I have
a feeling that I'm just going to see the Missandry pour through,
but we'll see. We'll see. We'll see. This woman
is a Miss Andrew that you're talking about. Cidal like hated
that woman. I think she hated the concept of boy moms.
She was going after the woman a little bit though. You're true.
Maybe a lot of it. She's like only only going after the Where
was the Missandry in that video? You're like just making up for
the for the boy moms who like didn't like their daughters, right?
And I feel like the concept of her really being Listen, that
was a totally normal relationship between mother and son, Cherry.
Okay. And and and kidology just hates men so much that she couldn't
see it. Okay. I can't stand on that opinion for more than 2 seconds.
So, I'm going to hit play on this video and just move forward.
Okay. Are we Are we good? There was no Missandry in that video.
Okay. I give up. I give up. I want to run away from whatever
I just said. I'm going to hit play on this. Mhm. Good god. Get
me out. Get me out. I think maybe you're just confused on who
Kidology is. I can't tell if you're joking or if you're confused.
I do feel like Kidology hates men based on the videos we watched
of her describing how she was a lesbian, but it was mostly because
of how she hated men and then she realized that one man actually
made her like come and then it was fine, I think. Yeah, Kali
has some weird going on. That's not That's not her hating men.
That's just her being a woman who leads men on and she's trying
to be like deep about it.
I do feel like she also hates men, but I I'm willing to give
it a different look. Did he try AI Jane testifies and rappers?
Okay, that's technically kind of related. She hates women, too.
Okay, I thought it based on some things from before, but you
know what? It could could go either way. Anyway, I this video
will tell us for sure. Okay, the answer will come from this video.
We'll flip the coin. Ling, she's the most amazing person I've
ever met. Eileen is in freaking jail. Here's Eileen's mug shot.
She was taking out credit cards without telling me and like maxing
them out and stuff. What I remember is I at first I paid for
it when you Okay,
this just seems like a super weird way to make Is this not bizarre?
What is going on here?
That's like this attractive young woman dating like a
mom grandma.
What the You first it out. Yeah, you did. But then but then down
the line you wish for Oh, hold on. Reuben Ruben donated $3. Why
she hate men when her name is Dex spelled backwards.
Okay, you're not funny, Ruben Ruben, but thank you for the three
bucks, buddy. Appreciate it. Guys, we have 30 minutes left on
the stream. We need to make it through this whole video. So,
I need you guys to dig deep. Okay, we are about eight subs away
from another hour on the stream. I need you guys to dig deep.
Pull it all together. Pull all your cash together. Sub on kick.
Throw primers on Twitch. Okay, I'll count every two primers I'll
count as five bucks. Okay, two primers equals five towards the
goal. Primers on Twitch. Get all the money in now. Money. Money.
Give me money. It's Friday. Let's do an all nighter. Let's go.
24 hours. Let's go. It's literally Wednesday. Okay, whatever.
We could still go 24 hours. We can go forever and ever and ever
and ever. You know what? We'll see how far we get. You know what?
I'll make this I'll make the next hour $30. Okay. You guys want
to sub? You guys want to make this work? We'll go 30. Ezekiel,
how can you call me jobless? I'm lit. You're literally looking
at me at the job. My job.
It's a job. It's a real job.
People with real jobs. Frenzy Freeze, thank for the primer. K87,
thank you for the primer. Let's go. W primers. Get them in right
now, guys. Open the Twitch stream and the kickstream. You need
to have both open at the same time, okay? Hear my voice in both
places, please. And thank you. We're going to continue with the
video. We have to make sure I can pay Cherry. Okay. But I can't
even
do not hang out with J for free. I do not do that. I'm eating
cat food just so I can pay Cherry. Please help me out, guys.
Primers. Any subs you can. All right. Panda Rider, thank for
the primer. Let's go. I need to have better food than just cat
food. Okay. Thank you. Thank you. Um Mew Crusty, thank you for
the primer. Let's Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. You're not
live on kick for me. They have some nets split going on. Yeah,
there's something going on that's with kick. I know, guys. Get
on both. Get on both right now. And we're hitting play on the
video. Okay. I also am done with my water and the other drink
I grabbed. I drink like at least 8 hours of fluid in a stream.
I swear to God. Okay. Wet or dry? Wet. But I'm having to I'm
getting close to downgrading to dry stalling a sloth. Okay, so
I need people to dig deep. Are you on your ball? No, I'm not.
I'm going to get more water though. Okay, give me a second. I'll
be right back. Okay, love you guys. I'm hitting play. We're listening
to the intro. I can hear my headphones. I will be right back.
Bring money to that. No, I don't know what you're talking about.
I remember not.
And she's a writer and she's into politics. She's like really
cool. I've meant to maybe go back to technical writing and then
I haven't. The point is, and I think you're too kind to say,
is that you married somebody with no resources. She's just so
lovely to me, and she treats me like a princess, and she's always
so considerate and nice and lovely to me. I'm the only one who
cooks in the house. I can be really
It's not that I always think I'm right, but I sort of do. You
know what I mean? My temperament, as I've gotten older, I'm much
less patient than I used to be. Can you throw this out? And also,
are you eating drinking the Diet Coke? No. No. Can you throw
that up? Just dropped it on the floor. Well, you can be a handful,
you know, um, in your way. Don't forget that you open it. You
always do that. Anyway, she's just my soulmate. Me and Eing have
decided to file for a divorce. She's just my soulmate. This is
going to be the most special video ever because I am here with
the most special person ever.
Uh, I would like to introduce you to my wonderful boyfriend Keith.
Hello. She is like quite a bit older than me. I'm 24, almost
25 and I'm 61. You're probably thinking, "Oh my god, again, I
really want you to give him a chance and, you know, give our
relationship a chance. You know, he is a boomer.
is quite a bit older than me, but actually just slightly younger
than my ex-wife, but pretty close. You know, if you want to judge
me, just go for it.
Hi, sweeties.
He found Terry. What? We got a Terry situation. Is that what
you're telling me? Yeah, they're not all old women. One of them's
an old man. Oh, let's go.
Let's go.
Uh, also, we had somebody came in. We got a raid from somebody.
Who raided? I don't see the raid anymore. Was it on Twitch? Wait,
where's the raid? Oh, it's the cherry raid. I see. Whoops. I
didn't see it. Cherry raid. One viewer. Let's go. All right.
Okay. We got old men, old women.
Everyone dating this girl. Let's go. So cute. No, you're so beautiful.
You're beautiful. You are. I don't know if it's just me, but
it seems that over the past few years, age gap relationships
have fallen drastically out of favor online. Not only are these
relationships seen as taboo, but Gen Z in particular are very
critical of what is increasingly being seen as an inevitable
power imbalance that exists in age gap.
It's so fake though. Nobody actually cares about the power imbalance.
Okay? They judge other people for power imbalance and then when
they end up in that situation, they'll just say, "No, no, no.
I'm fine. I know how to handle it. I'm okay." What are these
weirdos? There's these other weirdos who couldn't possibly handle
it, but I'm fine. I'm totally fine. Oh, also unrelated, but happy
Junth, everybody. East Coast, happy Junth. Wow. Wow.
Uh, how many primers did we get here? 1 2 3 4 five. Five. And
one regular sub. Okay, we'll go that is six. That's uh 15 bucks.
Wait, you call me you call me jobless, but this is basically
it is basically Friday because Junth is a federal holiday. Uh
so
tomorrow Oh, well it is basically it's kind of like a Friday.
True. Also guys, we are $12 or three subs away from another hour
on the stream. So I need you guys to dig deep. Get the money
in. Okay. Add more time to the timer right now.
Right meow. Okay, do it. And because of this, we've sort of drastically
transitioned from a time on YouTube roughly about 5 years ago,
I'd say, where age gap couples were very much a lot more accepted.
Pretty much just posting vlogs of their daily lives. Oh, that's
disappointing.
That's very disappointing.
Plant dad, thank you for the primer. Was that a primer or was
that just a notice? That was a primer. Thank you. into a far
more Oh yeah, this uh this young black one with this old old
busted ass white dude. That's not a good hairline right there.
Why would people Wait, what are you disappointed about this level?
It sounds like It sounds like she's finding her come up. You
a hater? Uh I just listen. She's doing what she got to do. Okay.
All right. All right. It's fine. It's fine. Maybe just like the
father she never had. Oh, is that because of her Hold on. Racist.
Is that because of her skin color? You assume she just never
had a father?
Excuse me. Say that. Excuse me. That's very racist. It's a very
crazy thing to say. What the what? What? What? Sensational taboo
representation of age gap relationships. Do you know this channel
or this channel? Love don't judge and truly are
that. Do you know this channel or this channel? Not that one.
This one that is like tales from the crypt keeper. What are we
doing here?
Oh my god. That's a rough 61. That's No, you have to pull up
their TikTok. They are disgusting. She twerks on him and everything.
It is He is disgusting. That is the roughest 61 I've ever seen
in my life. That is like she doesn't look a day over 85. Okay.
Jesus Christ. You can't tell how bad she look. Hold on. You need
I need to pull up their TikTok. Someone might need to pull up
a Tik Tok cuz I am up right now. Okay. Where's Staceia? Staceia
follow on Tik Tok. Why is this 20-year-old black dude dating
a Holocaust survivor? Okay, Ri said it right the second before
I did. God damn it. God damn it. Pull up the Tik Tok. I'll pull
up the Tik Tok as soon as I get linked. Where is Stia? She knows
these things. I mean, the say tick. I don't know. God, love don't
judge and truly are, in my opinion, contradictions. They're channels
that claim to normalize unconventional and taboo relationships.
Channels that claim My partner is 21.
Normalize
5 years older than my step relationship. But they do this by
sensation.
Cherry's got it. Hold on. Holding
God. We got a link coming in. Here's a link coming in. Oliver
6060.
Why? She throw it up. Let's review the Tik Toks. Let's go. The
top. Which one? Which one? We got to do the top ones. The pinned
ones. Yeah. Yeah. Ain't she
bro? Does she have teeth? Hold on. Does she have teeth? Um. Uhhuh.
That's why he love her. Okay. Hello. Hey. Had
ah. What is it?
fight his entire family. Let's go. Maybe she is. Maybe she's
got a different colored soul. Okay.
Why are you so old and wrinkly?
Okay. Oh, Jesus Christ. I'm sorry, but like you. I was a surfer.
Oh, that explains the age. She was a surfer for 30 years. She
was a surfer for 30 years. That's why she's not explain the jungle
fever with addiction. Um,
I don't keep going. We're reviewing. Keep it going. Keep it going.
The ones with the boyfriend. Who will be taken by the police
among us?
What? I don't get it. But also, he bleached his hair. I Yeah,
his hair has been like that for a while. Ah,
okay. Do you never open Tik Tok? I don't have Tik Tok. I literally
don't. No, I don't have Tik Tok at all. 0% Tik Tok. I don't do
it. What? Where? Look. Okay, there's one where she's like putting
her foot in her mouth. We're going to need you to pull that one
up. I don't I don't see it. I don't see it. Where is it? You
scroll past it, but that's good. I'm think that one pulled up.
Uh, we do, but I don't see it. To the right. How do I She's wearing
jeans on the couch. Her foot's literally Oh, go
very flexible for 60. Okay.
Half the chat is willing to date her now. I
All it takes is feet one time. You're my first choice. I troubles.
You're my first choice. That's crazy. Why did say TikTok is for
women, kids, and parents? I don't think so. This is like honestly,
is this just Wait, am I having a brain blast moment? Is this
just a regular woman, but instead of the Down syndrome filter,
they just put an old woman? No, it's not. Look at the leg. No,
this is an actual What? What? What did I just say? Why did it
say a child?
What are we doing? This just said as a child. Hold on. Hold on.
Where was I now? I actually lost it. One of these said is a child.
Why? Why did it say that? I just lost it.
Nope. Not that. Not that. Not that. Where was I? Dude, my TikTok's
so [__] By the way, it's right here. Your your brain
is as a child. Bullied as a child. Abused and abused physically
and mentally by parents was black sheep of the family. Trust
issues due to physically abusive relationships.
being homeless after running from Cali with seven kids to protect
my own life and their lives. Bro, how much money did she make
being like an extra in The Walking Dead? Okay, she's got the
zombie death reactions down pat.
I am a survivor. That's true. How did she make it out of Germany?
Cherry, she is a survivor. You are such a hater. Cheryl is a
real one. She came through the struggle. What is it with all
of the people who shouldn't be influencers having to talk about
how they're as kids in their Tik Toks and I just don't get it.
Keep that [__] to yourself.
Keep that [__] to yourself. That's more embarrassing
than when Chud Logic told me his dad's dead. Okay, which is I
still can't get over what a loser he is.
His dad's dead. Sorry, I'm I'm done. Okay, are we good to go
back under the Kidology video? Do we get We got enough review
of that poor old woman. We get enough laughs out of that poor
old woman. Okay, perfect. All right. This is a guy whose stepdaughter
is only five years younger than his or whose daughter is only
five years younger than his new wife. Rage baiting and almost
pimping out the taboo for clicks and likes. Pregnant at 13 and
we're not bad parents. Love don't judge. My ex-husband was sleeping
with my dad. Love, don't judge. Who does that? The overwhelmingly
negative response to these channels is no. What's that? Wait,
follow that YouTube channel. Don't judge. Love don't judge. Videos
we need to watch. All right. Love Don't judge. Uh we will pull
that up in the background. We will check out Love Don't Judge.
My ex-husband was sleeping with my dad. Love don't judge. Who
does that? The overwhelmingly negative response to these channels
is
telling of how these kinds of relationships are perceived. And
increasingly, age gap couples are a massive revenue source and
staple for these channels. And that's because for many of these
featured couples, being taboo, countercultural, and controversial
online is what sells and is a huge part of their attempt at social
media stardom. After all, if you want to appear on these channels,
you have to email their
love don't because in our social media age, all publicity is
good publicity. And nobody knows this better than 30-year-old
YouTuber, influencer, singer, songwriter, age gap relationship
advocate, and now podcaster, Julia Zul. Hi, sweeties. Hi, sweeties.
Hi, sweeties. Hi, sweeties. Hi, sweeties. Now, Julia is fascinating
to me. She is very much recognized from her very bright and vibrant
style, most notably her pastel and neon pink hair looks. I feel
like the vast majority of people online who are queer and LGBTQ+
have at least seen her face, have at least come across something
or other to do with Julia Zul. Julia is a Brazilian Portuguese
influencer and singer songwriter who started from very humble
beginnings. And until the age of 18, she lived with her mother
in Brazil. An introverted and shy child, Julia nonetheless had
a dream. And that dream to this day is to be famous. Make me
feel I'm alive again. Trained classically, she wanted to be a
singer, but not a classical oporatic singer in the niche world
of classical music. She wanted to be a more mainstream pop rock
singer. Such aspirations were only possible by immigrating to
London to attend college and then study music and hopefully get
into the music industry and the music scene that way. Julia often
relays the story of having only £25 in her pocket, a few suitcases,
and her dream, and moving on her own to London. And I moved to
London on my own when I was 18. And Julia truly hustled and grinded
on immigrating in order to get herself through college and into
music school. Now, almost immediately on moving to the UK, Julia
started her YouTube channel. And she started it with the intention
of uploading music. But this is a hard gig. This was definitely
an era of YouTube in which becoming a famous singer via uploading
YouTube videos of covers and even some original songs was very
trendy. Everybody with a voice wanted to be the next Dodie, Tessa
Violet, Ola Garland or even Justin Bieber. These singer songwriters
were proof that anybody could make it. But you had to garner
an audience and the best way to do that was to put out content
that people wanted to see like vlogs. Makeup to Okay. What? Just
just a real quick detour because I am uh scrolling through this
new YouTube channel that you told me about this video and just
this one video. I can't wait till we get to watch it. It's just
going to destroy all of you in chat. This girl has no ears or
jaw, but she still found love. And she's like rubbing it in your
face. Okay.
So, she put a shotgun in her mouth or under her jawline, right?
No. Right. Well, her ears off. She has no Oh, I have no idea
if she tried to kill herself. Oh, I I was I probably shouldn't
play with that too much on Twitch, but uh guys, 10 minutes left.
We're right there. Okay. I think we got 15. All those Twitch
subs. Uh, they got up to about halfway. We need like two subs,
three subs to make it, guys. We're very close. We're very close.
Okay, we're right there. I can't talk back if she don't have
a draw. Uh,
Q& A's and lifestyle videos, which is exactly what Julia
did. She needed to create an audience for her music. Now, one
thing about musicians and influencers is that they all have an
aesthetic and experiment with aesthetics throughout their careers.
Julia was no exception. As I said, she became known for dying
her hair bright fun colors.
Uh, okay. Well, Matrix user just walked up and decided to end
the showing for the night with 20
gifted subs. What the
Let's go. What do you mean end it? That's crazy.
I told him it's basically Friday. It is basically Friday, but
we're going to be here forever. I'm just kidding. Yeah, we'll
be here forever. Uh, let me throw up two hours on this stream
and we'll see where where we're going after that. Two hours from
that. Let's go.
Experimenting with punk goth pastel goth matrix. Thank you so
much styles. She was a proud and out lesbian. She was a recent
immigrant living on her own in a new country and it was clear
that her channel was the perfect outlet for her. It was obvious
that she was enjoying the YouTube experience of having a channel
to just be herself on and to upload videos onto. And what was
very noticeable about her first four or so years on YouTube was
that although her audience was small, they were very very loyal
and she was adored by all.
Uh Jojo Katy, thank you very much for the primer. Julia was a
very very likable person. She uploaded three times a week. She
had a full-time job on top of that. She was at university and
was just a very wholesome alternative woman doing story times,
Q& A's, hair and makeup tutorials vlogs for years. She never
got over. What do you mean? What do we need? I'm sorry. I don't
know why. Before instead of typing in chat, I just said, "What
do you mean out loud?" Never mind. You're good. You're good.
Okay. Uh, sorry. I'm laughing at um this girl really went off
the rails. She was like having a great time. This is like Kidology
setting up the fall of somebody, right? Like she just enjoyed
being a totally wholesome uh goth like pastel makeup
blogger and then it's going to be like and then she realized
she had to eat 70-year-old bucks to stay alive. Okay. Something
no person ever wants to realize. Dude, that's gross. I was thinking
about that. Like maybe she never had to eat it that she just
had to wear a strap on. Like you got to negotiate on that for
her sake. Hopefully. 10,000 views a video until she released
several very well prodduced music videos. But not even the relative
success of these music videos would prepare Julia for the views
that would come flooding in when she introduced the internet
to her girlfriend. I think she loves me. Julia Zulg is a brilliant
case study into the perils of influencing, the consequences of
having no boundaries with your audience, as well as the illusion
that love will conquer all. And by love, I don't just mean Julia's
love for her various partners. But in our day and age, the greatest
love of them all, the love of online validation and fame at all
and any cost. And so the question for this video is, how did
Julia Zulg go from being defended and adored by her fan base
and the LGBTQ plus community at large to being the recipient
of criticism and hate comparable to that of Amberlin Reed? It
Oh, where's where's Zoe? Amberlin reference. Okay, everybody's
favorite fat woman.
How's Amber's diet going? Okay, she losing it. She losing it
finally down a couple pounds this I'm sorry. Anyway, we continue.
Oh, it is a downfall video. We're gonna watch a total This woman
is gonna be dragged across the I don't I don't know why I wanted
to say I Dude, my brain's like broken right now. Never mind.
You know, you know, and I mean that during her prime, Julia grew
exponentially from virtually no subscribers to 300,000
subscribers by June 2022. However, since 2022, she's only gained
4,000.
Wait, 20 subs is only worth 2 hours. Well, I made 130. Yeah,
but I we'll see what happens. Subscribers, which for someone
with her then upload schedule, with her subscriber size across
all her platforms, as well as her views is most unusual. Oh,
greedy guy. No, you're lying. That's wrong. As I said, Julia
is fascinating to me. mainly because while she's incredibly human,
she very rapidly I did just yawn paused the video to just like
throw that at all of us. Uh this guy wanted to talk I had to
talk back.
and suddenly became very
I figured KCIP was good monies. It's literally cut in half right
now. No. Uh yeah, that's why I don't understand why you turned
on the Twitch just for them to maybe a couple of them to go chat.
It's like so stupid. I will just be your paint pig. Well, right
now
is $3 when the event diagram with a family tree and a polycule
people. Okay. People are saying that the kick channel is not
working, Cherry. That they only have the Twitch kick is just
not working at all. Okay. Okay.
But obviously that's not true. A lot of people on Kickuit. Oh
my god, I feel so famous. And I think because of this, at least
since her blowup, she has garnered two very polarized audiences
alongside her main audience. On the one hand, she has a a group
of diehard devout followers who will follow her through the underworld.
And on the other hand, she has an audience who are just as devout,
but have felt very betrayed or dismissed by her. And this audience
has congregated on Reddit and started the Julia Zulg Snark page.
Hi guys. And I'd say her main audience consists of people who
are subscribed to her but don't watch her anymore because it
just got a bit too much. They wished her the best and checked
out. And this deep dive is all about everything that was just
a bit too much. The first being Julia's neverending dilemma with
reconciling her once before fame with her highly publicized intimate
relationships. Going through Julia's content, one thing that
was immediately apparent to me was that she is always in a relationship.
Since starting her channel all the way back in 2014, I cannot
actually find evidence of her being single for more than a few
months. And based on my analysis of her, I think this is very
intentional to who she is. Julia is very much one of those people
who dreams of celebrity and therefore needs validation both publicly
and personally. The best way to get social validation is to be
famous. And the best way to get personal validation is to be
in a relationship. Couple that together and you have the perfect
recipe for making your romantic relationship content for mass
consumption on YouTube. Hitting two birds with one stone. and
fulfilling your need for both public and personal validation.
Julia will often say that she started her Okay, hold on one second.
Someone's telling me that Iran just hit a hospital in Israel.
What appears to be a direct hit from an Iranian ballistic missile
on Sroka Medical Center within the city of Baraba Beerba in southern
Israel. Uh-oh.
All right, cuz that's really going to work out for you. Wait
to Why would they do that?
uh because they have a bunch of rockets that sorry missiles that
are bordering on rockets that they could barely aim and then
they probably just targeted really badly and I don't think they
would have done that intentionally.
So her YouTube channel to do music, but her channel really didn't
suggest that. I would argue that it wasn't becoming a good singer
that Julia was after, but rather the wanting of celebrity that
comes from being a good singer. And because she wanted celebrity,
it was very easy for her to transition from struggling artist
ambitions into a fullyfledged influencer. As I said, Julia started
to gain views after uploading her initial music videos, but this
interest didn't nearly compare to the traction she would gain
a couple of months later after introducing her audience to her
girlfriend. Now, this girlfriend was different from her. Just
show the girlfriend. Julia's previous girlfriends had all been
around her age. One had even cheated on Julia with her own cousin.
But these relationships weren't anything to really rant home
about. Let me repeat, this girlfriend was different. I will call
this girlfriend Merrill and the Merrill era is indicative of
something characteristic of Julia Zol. Now the Merrill era represents
a relationship dynamic and cycle that we will see in Julia's
later relationships. And the dynamic,
uh, I can't tell, but I assume it's notable because it's, uh,
the person's own cousin, is that the girlfriend is always a reluctant
participant in being on her channel, at least until Eileen. Eileen
was special. But right now, we're briefly focusing on Eileen's
predecessor, Merrill. Merryill seems to have been Julia's first
serious long-term relationship. Julia made it known that Merrill
didn't want to be on camera from the get-go, establishing that
her channel was a beauty lifestyle channel and not a couple's
channel. I don't usually talk about my
here on this channel because it just usually doesn't come up
because it's a beauty and I'm sorry. You don't have to. She doesn't
even have to speak for me to say. Okay. There's just not a single
straight woman on the planet who dresses and does their makeup
this way, does their hair this way. I'm sorry. It doesn't exist.
And if you're gay, it's one of the two. That's just facts. Okay?
You don't have to talk about it. It's you've literally said it
in your appearance. Eternity fashion channel, but I'm completely
open. I just don't talk about the
uh the contacts a little bit. I just thought it would be random
and it wouldn't have anything to do with the channel. Is she
trying to look like Jinx, by the way? Which is like one of two
characters I know from League of Legends. I think this is the
second one you know, right? Uh, Amumu. That's
Well, because you asked me so much, don't think you're interested.
I do have a girlfriend. We've been together for about a year
and I would love to post the girlfriend tag with her here on
the channel, but she's not as open as me with all the social
media stuff. She doesn't even have a fake book in it. And I need
to respect her decision because people are different. Even though
I would love to film the tag with her, introduce her to you.
Anyway, she appears sometimes. I think some people already realize
who she is. So, yes, I do have a girlfriend, but for now, I cannot
post the girlfriend tag. But Julia would eventually very quickly
post a girlfriend tag and bring Merryill into the limelight.
What was immediately apparent was that Julia's views skyrocketed
when she brought Merryill onto the channel. And I'd say the main
reason as to these hypes in views had to do not so much with
them being in a lesbian relationship in as much as the evident
age gap and aesthetic differences between the two. Merrill was
in her 50s and Julia was 22 23. Now, Julia's audience loved Merrill.
Based on the forums and nostalgic posts in general, she was received
very positively. And I'd say the main reason for this positivity
had to do with Julia's audience's awareness that Merryill did
not want to be on the channel. This is how Merrill responds to
being on Julia's channel. And even though we can't see her face
or hear her real voice, it is clear that she doesn't want to
be there. And we are going to answer some of your questions.
Are you
Yes. Yes. Ready to Wait, is that is Kalji doing a thing or is
that how she said it? Yes. Yes. To be the star of the
Julia's partners not wanting to be featured on her channel is
a longunning theme. A thing that many of her detractors don't
like is how Julia routinely transforms her partners by, for instance,
dying their hair pink or some other bright color and gradually
seems to change her partner's appearance into what she wants,
whilst the partner reluctantly or dotingly goes with the flow.
Guys, today we will dye my girlfriend's hair and do a complete
transformation. And ta
uh Marty Epstein, thank you for the five gifted. Let's thank
you. Thank you.
For instance, with her first UK girlfriend, Julia dyed her hair
and gave her a transformation. And this was what Julia had to
say about this ex looking miserable after she gave her what I'd
assume to be. I can't tell if it's Codology blurring because
those people didn't want to be in the channel or the woman who
blurred it herself. I I literally can't tell. I assume that some
of the newer women do want to be on the channel or don't, sorry,
still don't want to be on the channel and they're not blurred.
An unwanted makeover. She decided to review her exes with her
then partner as one does. She just looks unhappy. I think, poor
thing. I think she probably didn't want to film YouTube videos
with me and I was just like probably insisted a lot and she was
just standing on camera like looking unhappy. Now, Julia knew
that her content was becoming pretty much. It's all Julia censoring
the face and voice, okay? Dependent on Merill's appearance, and
it was very obvious that Merrill loved Julia and would do anything,
even be on camera for her. She'd basically create hype around
her music by inserting a Q&A or vlog with Merrill in between.
And of course, like with all her girlfriends, Julia transformed
Merryill. That's like me with with Sherry. I'm like, "Hey guys,
I'm going live." And people like, uh, I'm like, Cherry's going
to be there. And they're like, yes,
that's it's the same thing. Okay, that is not that's not actually
true. I have blurred out her face, but Merryill just looks like
she's so done with YouTube. Um, the Merryill era ended quite
abruptly, and the publicity of their relationship seemed to be
at least somewhat of a part of that breakup. The YouTube channel
seemed to be wearing Merryill down and I understandably don't
think she could handle it. Especially having strangers, albeit
a minority, commenting about how she was a sugar mommy, how sick
or how abnormal their relationship was. And at the same time,
a prerequisite of being with Julia, contrary to what she herself
may believe, is that being in a relationship with her necessitates
being in a public relationship with her. She doesn't just do
this with her intimate partners, but with her mother as well.
Say hi, sweeties.
Oh, hell no. With such enthusiasm, we're going to her mom and
her. The girlfriend is older than her mom. Uh, she is. That's
so gross.
I'm not a fan of her mom's teeth either, which is unfortunate.
But I think if Merryill had outright declined to be on the child,
like
mom's a eight out of 10. Wouldn't wouldn't with the teeth like
who's asking? That would have spelled the end. That's basically
what that was like. Relationship in and of itself. And arguably
it probably did. But this wasn't cause for tears. Oh no, it was
not. In fact, it was cause for celebration. Basically, something
really, really amazing and magical happened to me. About a month
after Julia and Merryill broke up, Julia would have her first
of many viral videos in September 2018.
Hi, sweeties.
I'm so cute. No, you're so beautiful. You're beautiful. You are.
You look gorgeous. No, you look so beautiful. I wish everybody
here could see how beautiful you look in person.
Welcome back to the channel. Reaching a whooping 2.1 million
views. Meet my girl lesbian age. Can we just watch this video?
Where is or definitively establish Julia Zul's brand. No longer
was she a singer songwriter or even a I'm pretty confident we're
going to do this. And based on some of the videos we saw at the
beginning, I'm guessing this is like the direction it takes as
in like this just becomes her thing. alternative fashion vlogger.
From now on, she would be known as the 23-year-old influencer
dating a 60s something year old woman. So, how old are you, J?
So, you probably already know about my age if you follow me cuz
I've said it before, but I'm 24, almost 25. Some people think
I'm like 15 just cuz I have colorful hair, but I'm not. I'm 24.
Oh, she highlights it with the other person there to.
And how about you my love and I'm 61. By October 2018, Julia
had u-hauled by
Okay, hold on. Hear me out. Also, if you're eating, stop for
a second. She is old, but she's very fat. Okay? And she's very
fat. And I don't know if you've ever like been
around fat people. They've got like rolls and stuff like that.
You pick up the roll, it's very moist in there, right? Like the
sweat gets trapped in there. But if you think about it, keeping
your skin moist, it like keeps it very youthful. So maybe her
vagina is stuck under all of that fat has actually just been
super hydrated and is like very Never mind. Never mind. What
is wrong with you? What are you talking about? A just very possible
that underneath all of that that she's like a lot younger than
61.
There's some weird look a day.
It doesn't look a day over 40 down there. You know what I mean?
This video is going to get this video is going to be up. Hold
on. Let me let me see. I have to I have to send Cherry this thumbnail.
There's a There's a music video behind the scenes that is Uhhuh.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
Cherry, look at that. Just give me your immediate reaction to
that information. Oh no.
Oh. Um,
is this everything I was describing? What the What the [__]
is this? It's pretty bad. It's pretty bad. Her skin looks amazing.
Okay. I Yeah, her skin looks great. I feel like I was on to something.
Went super viral. Keep going. I mean, love of my life.
So, just to reiterate, Julia and Mel broke up by mid 2018. Julia
and Eileen started dating in around July, August of 2018. Had
moved in together by October 2018 and were engaged. It's so cute.
They're so cute together.
Why does it feel so fake? I don't know, but I think it has to
do with the lack of like charge between them. Okay. And I think
they identified that as an issue and they will fix that very
shortly.
The woman on the old woman looks like she is a a dog in bed.
It looks like she will go in. I Yeah, but I'm saying Yeah, I
know what you mean. Like she looks like she puts on the leather
pig face.
I just imagine she is like some type of freak.
Uh maybe maybe that's where she finds them. Maybe she goes to
like gay bars. She just finds like the freakiest, craziest person
she can. Yeah, I don't know. That by October 2018 and were engaged
to be married by December 2018. Love, don't judge, but we do.
And here's my judgment. I think a lot of this bizarre speed rolling
of the relationship was driven by the social media frenzy around
their relationship and wanting to keep riding that wave. Julia
and Eileen were immediately picked up by the mainstream media.
I know things have moved quite fast with us, but you know, sometimes
that's just the way it is. This just feels right. We're together
because we love each other. As Julia very beautifully said once,
we couldn't not be together, you know. Now, I'll call this the
Bachelor effect. I'd say that the vast majority gravity right
there. What's that? That she's talking about gravity right there.
Once she got that close, it's really hard to pull apart. The
Bachelor effect. I'd say that the vast majority of Juvine was
compounded by the bachelor effect. The bachelor effect is basically
when you love a person, but a large part of what compounds that
love is the fairy tale romance that is created by the public
perception, the public validation, and the public eye being on
that love/ relationship. Your love for the person grows within
a framework fostered by everything that makes a reality TV show
like The Bachelor. Millions of eyes are on you. The relationship
and love is what makes you famous. Money is flowing in because
of that love. Everybody in the relationship is putting their
best self and their best foot forward because everything is done
in front of a camera. Now, it doesn't mean that the people experiencing
this effect aren't actually in love. Julia and Eileen were clearly
in love. The contestants on The Bachelor do indeed oftent times
fall in love. But it definitely means that a lot of things that
are important, that are boring, and that are very everyday, which
go into building a successful long-term relationship, are overlooked.
And this is why The Bachelor's relationship success rate sits
at a measly 11%. One comment sums up a lot of what people were
thinking on seeing Julia's proposal to Eileen a mere four to
5 months after her breakup from Merrill. I'm going to sound like
a hater, but I'm not. I'm so pleased to see Okay, I'm sending
you guys back to uh Kick, by the way. Seems like Kick's back.
We're all going back to Kick. I will see you guys there shortly.
Okay, ending the Twitch stream. Twitch is like having issues
for me as well now. I hope it's fine with just one, but I am
not going to have both going at the same time. Okay, I love you
guys. See you in a little bit. Bye. Bye. In the Twitch channel.
Sorry to kick you guys around a whole bunch. Okay. You got to
head over to kick.com/j2. Okay. I'll put it I'll pin it for you.
Okay. I'll pin it for you in the chat. You got to head back to
the kick cuz I don't want to shut off. I don't want to. I finally
kicks back and I would have to shut off multireaming mode or
I'd have to turn it on and I don't want to do that. So, back
to kick. Back to kick. Back to kick. Back to kick. Pinned.
Go. Yes. Okay. I love you guys. Bye. None. Nothing I just sent
to a chat worked. It's fine. people fall in love no matter gender,
age, race, life circumstances, etc. But I think our society is
seriously putting too much pressure and deeming marriage to be
this fairy tale. I think if two people truly love each other,
they wait until they get to know each other. They see the bad
sides of each other. They go through hard times together. They
get to fully know each other's families and friends. Then they
decide if it's something they truly want to commit to. I've seen
a number of friends get married quickly and then divorce right
after. There's nothing wrong with it, of course, but I just think,
what's the rush? If you love someone, that's great. Why do we
have to prove ourselves with a piece of paper? Well, there was
a reason why Julia and Eileen had to prove themselves with a
piece of paper so soon into their relationship. The relationship
was very, very good for Julia's channel. And as a YouTuber, I
know that when we get good views on a video, it's it's very difficult
to overcome the temptation and the urge to capitalize on that
thing and produce more of that exact same thing because all the
receptors in our brain are telling us that this is right, that
this is good. Every single thumbnail and title after her viral
video introducing Eileen was it was a riot. Uh they're good.
They're good thumbnails and titles. Okay, there
a week in my life featuring my girlfriend. London fashion week.
But hold on. My girlfriend and a week in my Now are are those
the same thing or does she actually get a kitten? Okay. Life
featuring my girlfriend. London fashion week with my girlfriend.
Trip to Berlin with my girlfriend.
Reading hate comments with my older girlfriend. Two girls, one
cake. I I cannot find the words to say how I feel. Julia was
gaining astronomical views and subscribers. Her dream of celebrity
was coming true. So why wouldn't she propose to the very person
whom a she believed was her soulmate and B whose existence was
making all her dreams of celebrity come true. And this brings
us to the Eileene or should I say the Julene era. Now, Julia
and Eileen's whirlwind romance brought Julia to the masses in
a way that Merryill's reserved demeanor never could. As I said,
Eileen was special. Girlfriend. Girlfriend. Girlfriend. Her name
is Eileene.
Eileen.
That's right. Eene. And I'm so happy to be introduced to you
guys particularly. It was immediately noticeable that Eileen
was far more comfortable on camera, marking a stark departure
from Julia's previous partners, who were all very much reluctant
participants. I has it that this was, to be honest, Britney Simon's
analysis went harder for this age gap couple. Um, I could see
that. I could see Britney Simon trying to do analysis of this,
but for now, I'm good with Kology stuff. Okay. Ky's got a lot
of views on this. I didn't even know about it before Kology.
She knows a lot about Tik Tok. I'll have to I'll maybe I'll go
look for some of the Britney Savage. Also, a large part of what
made falling in love with Eileen such a quick thing for Julia.
She'd never had a partner who actually wanted to be public or
enjoyed the spotlight as much as she did. Naturally, their proposal
as well as their wedding preparations and eventual wedding went
absolutely viral. Mainstream media was truly lapping this up
legally. Why? And why? It was a day to remember Julia and Eileen.
The day they pledged to love each other forever. You promise
to be loving, faithful, and loyal. What? Why would Why would
they care? I don't know. I don't know. It's I mean, I think the
same reason we all care. It's like uh we don't know what's going
on here. For the rest of something's wrong and we can't put our
finger on it. I will. The couple met on Tinder last summer and
instantly hit it off. We were very very connected from the beginning,
but they acknowledge some are curious about the age difference
between them. Her wedding preparations were closely documented
not just by Julia herself, but by the media, and her wedding
was an affair to remember. It was a very, very cool wedding.
Now, it's important to remember that Julia married Eileen in
June 2019, having only met her in around August 2018. Eileen
was her soulmate after all. And as I said, the bachelor effect
was in full swing with these two love birds. There was inevitably
a lot about Eileen that Julia could not possibly know. Everything
I'm about to say is public and is either sourced from public
records, some up about to get said. You don't you don't you don't
lead with trust me this is all true. I know it's going to seem
not true. You don't lead with that unless there's some crazy
[__] about the beast. All directly from Eileen's
own YouTube channel because yes, she has her own YouTube channel
courtesy of Julia of course. Eene DeFest is an American citizen
born in 1957 who moved to London in 2009. If you go on her channel,
she speaks very openly about her experiences with drug addiction.
Oh, she had living in the States. how she moved to London with
no money and was homeless, showering and sleeping in Heathrow
airport. However, what is pertinent to our story is how after
getting married, Julia wanted the couple to go to Los Angeles
where Eileen had previously lived. There was also a film crew
from Love Don't Judge or Truly that was filming a reality documentary
series about them at the time. However, this was the first sign
of trouble in paradise and one of the issues with what I have
observed as being what I'd call the Julene dynamic. A plot hole
for the documentary and on Julia's channel was that Eileen had
met Julia's family in Brazil, but Julia hadn't met any of Eileen's
family and friends in the US. In short, Julia wanted to go to
the US. Eileen was a bit more
hesitant. And the reason was only made clear after Julia uploaded
two videos revealing that on landing in New York as a newly married
couple on honeymoon, Alen,
I was going to say it. Oh, that she's getting arrested. Had been
detained and arrested at the airport for car theft. A 14-year-old
warrant had been out for Eileen's arrest and another warrant
for another car. Julia uploaded a video about this where she
was clearly destroyed and amazing. Okay. Eileen spent time in
female prison. Yeah. Yeah. She's dog. Okay. This There's a woman
who knows the ins and outs of a vagina like very few on the planet
do. Okay. That's
I I s a bunch of things just became crystal clear. Okay. Pig
mask. Yeah. had immediately gotten herself into debt in order
to bail Eileen out of jail and to cover all of her legal costs.
Allegedly, Eileen had been arrested in 2005, was released, but
failed to appear for her next court date. She'd left the state,
then moved to London, and had chosen not to return to the US
until she was in a financial position to do so. Based on things
such as company checks, online sleuths at the time were also
able to find out that throughout her adult life, Eileen had allegedly
gone by numerous aliases. She herself admitted to having been
arrested in London in 1999 for credit abuse. She'd allegedly
incorporated many companies under her various aliases. One of
these numerous companies was called Egay Design Limited, and
its business partners are listed as Mrs. Eileene Gray and M.
Eileene Ashton Ryder, two of Eileen's alleged aliases. Now, according
to a storytime video, okay,
I just want to meet Eileen now. Eileen's got stories. Eileen's
lived a very colorful life. Okay,
this is this woman's wanted in multiple countries. Posted by
Eileen on her channel. Her identity was stolen. I was, you know,
really furious that this woman had stolen my passport. I didn't
really want to have anything to do with it. And what I went through
is a spot. Uh cuz she's in victim mode. I think I think that's
what it is. She actually also sounds shockingly like Emir. What
the stolen my passport? I didn't really want to have anything
to do with it for That's crazy. What the [__] Looking
at the screen, I was like, Emmy, I was processed. I was treated
just like garbage. It's actually so offing. What the That's like
exact.
That's crazy. The way people are treated are arrested. You if
you've ever been, you know, unfortunately for me, I have, and
it's a terrible experience. If you've ever had this kind of thing
happen, most people won't have had it happen. We can cure so
many emirs right now. We have the ability. We have the power.
Somebody send this to Queenman. Most people won't have been arrested
in their life. But if you have, there is an immediate dehumanization
that occurs and it is absolutely
nauseating. Now, I'm not saying that this is a lie. If this is
true, I am so very sorry that this happened to her. And yet,
based on everything, we're going to learn about Eileen and Julia's
financial arrangement. And bas this dog is chilling. This dog
is big chilling. Wait, you think that's attractive? No. I said
we could cure so many Emmy simps purely on the scandal
that I can see the tiniest dog.
You think they she should get something kind of like stripes,
something like a Doberman so that she's it's not quite as obvious.
I don't think you would dog your way out of being that size.
I just don't think it happens. be why many people believed that
Eileen had a rather shady history and started to eye this age
gap relationship suspiciously. Now, while this was all happening,
I would say that this was definitely a golden age on YouTube
for lesbian couples content. I don't know why exactly, but the
algorithm was eating up these couples at the time, especially
if they did morning, nighttime routines or kissing challenges.
Actually, sorry. I just answered my own question. If there's
I just don't understand why the algorithm loves lesbians kissing.
Why would the algorithm just love lesbians kissing challenge?
Why would Why would Why would men click on that? That's disgusting.
Woman kissing then. Yeah. And oh my god, just off the top of
my head, I remember how many of these channels, these couples
there were. There was Eric and Freda, Sarah and Rachel, Angela
and Nina, Alexis and Lillian, Berkeley and Pory, Kristen and
Steph, Sadie and P. Basically, if you were a hot lesbian couple,
if you made out, if your thumbnail featured you lying in bed
together, you were guaranteed at the very least half a million
views. Now, Julia and Eileen soon became one of the many faces
of this kind of content. They did the chapstick challenge, their
morning
What the went absolutely
viral. Hi sweeties. Welcome to our morning road. Dude, it's crazy.
We always cuddle in our sleep. So, we usually wake up more or
less like this. I literally have the best girlfriend ever. Every
day when I wake up next to her, I just feel so incredibly lucky
and grateful for having her in my life and for being able to
wake up every morning with Are a bunch of these videos just deleted
or cuz I'm looking around to see if I can find these videos.
I think a bunch of the Eene content is deleted. That's not music
video stuff. It seems someone I love and admire so much. I just
find these videos kind of when you realize why is your name butt
snipper? If I like want to vibe with what you're typing, you
understand I have to say butt sniffer before I say anything.
Butt sniffle. Either way, that's exactly what I'm thinking. I'm
thinking of the morning breath. I don't understand people like
this. There might be something wrong with me. I don't understand
why people want to smell each other's breath in the morning.
This is off.
Curious. Very curious. This guy is this guy. Is this really the
guy you wanted to make your ally here, Cherry? That morning breath
is his problem, but his name is quite literally butt sniffer.
Yes, exactly. That's what I'm saying. I like regretted it as
soon I was like vibing with the comment and then I go to say
their name and I'm like, okay, I made a couple mistakes. The
amount of setup that goes into staging these seemingly organic
scenes of everyday life and we always kiss and hug and talk about
the day ahead before getting up. And that's one of my favorite
parts of our morning. We often wear these robes in the morning
as well.
That's totally fake. Who would ever believe this? Who would ever
believe this? This is so fake. We always have a lot of fun together.
Whatever we do, even if we're just at home, I think especially
if we're just at home, actually, we usually do some work from
home on the computer. And I love that. is very very nice because
we can get so much work done but still spend some time together.
So we usually sit like this on the sofa with our laptops or Ien
sits on the desk and I sit on the sofa. Please remember that
Eileen works from home. It's very very important information.
Now what you'll notice from these videos is that clearly Eileen
was very very comfortable being on camera. The couple had weathered
the storm of Eileen's arrest, made it back to London and were
settling into married life. Apparently, everything was hunky
dory, and it had to be. A big part of Julia's brand is that she
basically at this time became an advocate for age gap relationships
between consenting adults. Although most of her loyal viewers
are from the lesbian community, most of her virality on YouTube,
on Tik Tok, and especially on Instagram revolves around the age
gap and especially how taboo it is for an older woman to be in
a relationship with a younger woman. people have a hard time
accepting it because they see older women only as mothers or
grandmothers. They don't see them as individuals and as beings
as well. So to think that I'm sorry I listen I appreciate this
woman's ability to see through to the being beneath
this the Eileen's like exterior instantly saw this being No,
I saw it right away. I can see she's a freak. She might She is
big as a hog, but she makes a girl oink.
I can tell she's not the one who squeals in bed. Woman could
be interested in someone younger and having fun and being
it kind of offends people somehow. I feel like people are a little
bit more comfortable with seeing an older man with a younger
woman because they don't see older men the same way they see
older women. Julia is very big on dispelling what she perceives
as being the myths around age gap relationships. That these relationships
are always unequal. That the young partner is always a gold digger.
That it's impossible for someone young to be physically attracted
to someone exponentially older than them. Now, Julia gets these
accusations thrown at her left, right, and center. So, I can
completely understand her being very outspoken about it. Remember,
it was Julia who bailed Eileen out of prison. It was Julia. Like,
Julia is clearly not a gold digger here. There's some element
of, okay, the content works really well with the older woman,
but I mean, she's clearly not a gold digger. She's just throwing
in her money. There's a lot of other old women, old lesbians,
okay, old died in the wool lesbians that you could go find would
be just as desperately like ravenous in bed as this Eileen woman.
Okay? You don't there's lots een's debts debts that she hadn't
even known about mind you and was now in debt herself clearly
Julia the younger partner was the bread winner the provider I've
been called a gold digger online a bunch of times just because
I'm younger and that comment really really upsets me because
I've worked so hard to have everything I have and if you don't
mind me saying that please I do you know earn more. It just makes
me so upset like when people say things like that. This all speaks
to what her too dubbed as the Julene dynamic. Now, since publicizing
her age gap relationships online, Julia has received a lot of
hate, but she's also received a lot of what I would call concerned
criticism. And this has to do with a few things. Firstly, it
was very noticeable to Julia's viewers that she had adopted a
very particular influencer persona which a lot of people, especially
since her marriage, didn't buy into. There is definitely something
a bit uncanny valley about Julia at times and I personally don't
think it's put on. I think she is genuinely this way. I basically
sum up this persona as follows just based on my observations
of her. Julia has clearly always wanted to be famous, to be a
celebrity, and it's Uh, I will be right back. I'm just going
to grab some food real quick. I'll be right back. Almost as if
over the years she's cultivated her personality, her mannerisms,
and her entire presence around having a camera on her 24/7. Her
audience seemed to have definitely noticed how her appearance
has changed over the years. That is, she went to Turkey to get
veneers and was heavily criticized for that. She gets cosmetic
procedures and she's constantly bleaching and dying her hair,
which although it looks absolutely amazing, so cool, inevitably
causes damage. But that damage doesn't matter because her dyed
hair is her trademark. It makes her stand out. And I think people
not liking her has definitely been something hard for Julia to
accept because this is who she really is in her eyes. Secondly,
as I said, Julia is exceptionally influencercoded,
but she also has absolutely no boundaries with her audience.
I've actually never seen a content creator or influencer have
such a lack of boundaries with their audience. Julia and Eileen's
marriage was a three-way relationship between Eileen, Julia,
and their audience. Julia overshares, which as a result conflicts
with the influencer persona she has. And by overshare, I mean
the kind of oversharing that makes her audience uncomfortable
and uneasy as opposed to the kind of oversharing that breaks
stigmas or is a cry for help. There's a reason why influencers
don't overshare. And if they do overshare, it's usually a cry
for help or to clickbait. And if it's to clickbait, the influencers
are usually far enough removed mentally and financially to never
take the hate personally. Think Tanamongu or even better early
Trisha Pitus. the ultimate oversharing influencer who clickbaited
and trolled her whole career. I'd say that the problem with Julia
Zel, like with early Trisha, is that she does clickbait. She
does overshare. Yet, unlike early Trisha, Julia expects her audience
to buy into who she authentically is and expects her audience
to like her as they used to. And who Julia authentically is already
comes across as very influencer fake. I do tend to sympathize
with her more than her detractors just because in my opinion.
One second here. The IRGC got jokes. What is this RGC statement?
We struck the Soraka site. This is the hospital which was secretly
used as a military facility for highle meetings of occupation
leaders. Large caches of weapons were stored beneath it. So this
is uh Iran, the IRGC, the Iranian revolutionary guard corp saying,
"Hey, we struck that Israeli hospital cuz there are weapons underneath
it." Little tongue and cheek. Little tongue and cheek joke right
there. Okay. I I don't think the Israelis are going to appreciate
it. What's that? Oh, wait. Is that like a a Gaza joke? Yeah,
it's a joke that like if Israel strikes a hospital, it's like
they're like, "Oh, there weapons beneath it." Yeah. Oh, they're
making jokes. Is that them? That would probably actually be them.
Listen, they're like their country is about to be like overthrown,
okay? They're they're making jokes while they can. I was told
there's not going to be a country there. I mean, their supreme
leader is now supreme leading the his family and friends into
Pakistan, okay? He's not even hanging out in Iran anymore. He's
out. He knows Osama bin Laden managed to hide out in the in the
mountains of Pakistan. That's where he's that's where he's placing
his bets. Okay? It won't be anywhere near Iran right now. of
masking due to her mental struggles. But then she also has this
persona and when that is muddled all together, it unfortunately
doesn't make people like her very much. And through the years,
this has proved to be a very very toxic dynamic that she has
with her audience and it mirrored the toxicity of her marriage.
Now, there's something very evident in Julia's dynamic with her
elder partners pre and post Eileene. And this is that she a as
I've already mentioned likes to transform them and b she infantilizes
them. And this Wait, which one was this one? I don't remember
this one. What the? That's not Eileen, is it? Did I like get
home Weight Watchers? Eene lost some weight right here. Likes
to transform them. And B, she infantilizes them. And this infantilizing
is something that a lot of our culture generally does toward
older people. Talking to them like children, using exaggerated
language, treating them like pets. And I think it's telling that
Merrill, who didn't like this dynamic at all, was replaced by
Eileen, who, for lack of a better phrase, locked that [__]
up. You're so cute. No, you're so adorable. So now that I'm officially
back
is kind of based. I'm not going to lie. I'm kind of a fan of
Eene. Oh, baby. We can at least have lunch together before I
do a little bit more work. Oh, great. Can't wait. Here you go,
darling. Baby, I'm sorry. I got to hold my leggy there. Great.
Oh, it looks fantastic. Can you throw this out? And also, are
you eating drinking the Diet Coke? No. No. Can you throw that
out? Just dropped it on the floor. Thank you. Sure.
Diet Coke here. Can you open that? Uh, no. It's not It's not
cold. It's from I don't know. It's from earlier. I didn't open
it. Well, I I certainly didn't open it. It's brand new. No, it's
not brand new. I think it's just cold cuz it's cold in the house
cuz I didn't open a new Diet Coke. Well, I mean, you're welcome
to. I'm just saying don't forget that you open them. You always
do that. Here you go, my love. Wasteful.
One thing that was immediately suggested by Eileen's arrest and
the context leading up to that arrest is that Eileen doesn't
like taking responsibility for her actions. She's bad with money
and her job resume is is mysterious to say the least. In short,
since Eileen's arrest scandal, it became abundantly clear that
Eileen had no money. This fact made the infantilizing even more
apparent. The infantilizing
Julene dynamic was one that allowed the elder partner, the designated
child, to enjoy the validation of being showered in love and
affection. But on the downside, it also, like with a child, allowed
them to not take adult responsibility for their actions. Eileen
gets arrested and Julia bails her out, pays her debts and even
claimed in the original video that the whole ordeal made her
love Eileen even more. But the person who always suffers from
a not good. Okay. Child or an infantilized adult not taking responsibility
for their actions isn't the child or the infantilized adult.
It's the parent, the caregiver, the Julia who infantilize them
and then wonder why the child won't grow up. Just from watching
their content together, in my opinion, Eileen loved this infantilizing
dynamic. Contrary to the belief of many of the millions viewing
their relationship online, if anything, Julia was Eileen's sugar
mommy. She was the one taking care of her. She was paying for
everything. She cooked allene
your meals. I'm the only one who cooks in the house and I always
cook vegetarian cuz I don't know how to cook meat because I've
been a vegetarian for so long. So, I've been eating just my stuff,
but I don't know when you actually stopped eating meat. There's
only one instance that I could find of Eileen actually standing
up to being infantilized. Now, this involved a rather major controversy
at the time where Julia had tooth surgery and Eileen didn't go
with her because, you know, being the infantilized partner means
you don't have to do grown-up things like take your partner to
and from surgery. Now, as I said, this was quite a big controversy
at the time just because not only did Julia walk an hour to the
hospital, but after having the procedure and being under anesthetic,
she was clearly still woo and it took her 3 hours to find her
way back home. So, Phoebe went to work and I'm walking home and
it's about an hour
long walk, but because I had surgery and everything, it's taking
me like 3 hours.
There's still like a long way to go, but I found this and now
like I'm highly
entertained. Oh, wow. Amazing. I'm listening to Is this her version
of uh Is she filming herself after tooth surgery? Okay, she's
loopy and but she's actually just filming herself. God, she's
her own mom
and like having a great time. Red lights damp. Yes.
Anyway, Julia, after expressing how disappointed this whole ordeal
made her feel, immediately gives Eileen all the excuses typical
of a parent not letting their naughty child take responsibility
for their wrongdoing. And I was wrong not to go. That is the
truth. I was wrong not to go. And you gave me a choice as you
always do. You were probably too easygoing. I mean, yeah, really.
It's my Am I picking up hints of like a Trump cadence here? You're
probably like uh too easy goinging even. You always do. You're
probably too easygoing. I mean, yeah, really. There's like there's
like something Trumpian right there that I picked up. My fault
because I mean, in all honesty, we're being like 100% open here,
right? Yeah. In all honesty, I was I was a little a little upset
with you that you didn't go to my surgery, but it was kind of
my fault because you asked me if oh, do I really need to? Is
it she from New York and old? Oh, I was like, oh, no, don't worry
about it. I don't mind. But really, I mind it, but I didn't want
to be a pain in the ass. So, it was really my fault. I mean,
in my opinion, it's not really a big deal because it wasn't like
a surgery surgery. It was more an extraction than anything else.
Although, it was a little more complicated than that. I mean,
I was just upset when I was there because I did feel like a little
alone. But, but thinking back now and before the actual surgery,
why did she go for these old hags when she could get anyone?
Uh, Spruce Willis, don't be jealous, okay? This hag eats box
better than you. Okay, this old hag can get a relationship with
a hot young like YouTube influencer and you can't do [__]
Spruce, how would you get your [__] together? Okay,
get your [__] together. Ask, email, ask her for some
tips. What's up? Well, to be fair, the internet only cared about
Julia when she got with an old hag. So, if anything, Julia is
like obsessed with being relevant.
So, she's actually gotten mind into old hags.
Uh, and spoiler alert, possibly old dudes as well. Well, I didn't
mind. And, uh, it's not a big deal because it was such a minor
thing and I told you I didn't mind. So, it's not your fault.
So,
it's actually disgusting how powerful chatters are that they
caused this. He caused this. God, this girl could have had a
normal life and instead she had like one chatter who's like,
"Wouldn't it be funny if you like dated an older woman and then
kept like donating and watching and donating and watching until
that eventually became a reality." Okay. This woman was groomed
into liking old people just like Finster was groomed into being
trans. All right. Yeah. Exactly.
expect that I should should be with you and it was reasonable
for you to expect that and I failed you in that. I mean I just
did. It doesn't mean I failed you in our relationship but I but
I failed you there and I was you know responding from my own
selfish like you know if you need me to go surprisingly Eileen
doesn't give in and actually stands up for herself. So I was
saying that that I really failed you that day. I mean I really
really did and it there's no blame that should be placed on you.
No, please let me let me let me finish. I have a lot to say about
this and I need you to please say it and that is that you were
right. I mean it's not a question of right. You weren't in any
way wrong. I'm somebody that's used to doing things alone but
I didn't really think it through that she I you know you might
think how could you not think it through? It's dental surgery
and you know it's okay. Don't worry. I don't want you to feel
bad and I don't want anyone to think badly of you because of
that because it's such a minor thing. Like don't worry. But it's
what it's what happens. I'm sorry. And it's my fault really because
I No. Yeah, it is because of the way I am with you. Cuz you're
my baby. So, not just with that, but with things in general.
You know, some hates it. Kidology hates people being in love.
Kidology is perma alone. Even though she has a partner, she's
like perma alone. She just hates the idea of these people being
in love. What is wrong with Kidology?
Why can't she just be happy for these people?
Come on, kiddology.
Come on.
Doesn't do this, doesn't she? Doesn't do that. Yeah. And it's
because I spoiled you. You do indulge me. You do indulge in your
life. Now, this is a perfect example of an infantilized adult
trying to take responsibility for their wrongdoing and being
told, "No, you're my baby." Cuz you're my baby. Being given the
thumbs up to weaponize their incompetence. Now, even though there
was this dynamic between them, there was something a little conflicting.
Although Julia was clearly the bread winner in this relationship,
she was also very dependent on Eileen in order to be the bread
winner. The two were living in Eileen's apartment and Eileen
was essentially what was making Julia money. Their content together
became more sensational and clickbaity. For instance, there was
the infamous pregnancy situation that wasn't. I can't wait to
see my results. Yeah, me too. Eileen and I had been talking for
the last year about maybe starting a family, but we kept going
back and forth because obviously it's a very big and serious
decision. We have to consider a lot of things including our age
difference. Yeah. So, I took a fertility test. Who is he talking
to? Okay. Are you ready? Oh, I'm talking to myself. Oh, I've
got a new avatar, but it's all Okay, let's look together. We'll
fix We'll fix We'll fix. Give me a second. Oh my gosh. We're
the average number of age.
Oh, baby, that's so great. Oh, baby, that's really fantastic.
I'm elated for Julia that everything was sound with her fertility,
but I'm confused as to why a film crew was there. This morning,
actually, we opened a test that I took, a fertility test, and
we found out that
everything is good. So based on that, we've made a decision.
And are you ready? Are you ready? I'm ready, baby. We are going
to start a family.
Oh my god. My friend's face is me.
Oh my god. But we want to wait a couple of years first. Done.
Why would you announce that? What the I love influences so much.
People were really annoyed with how much of a um how much of
a nothing burger the whole situation was and also how it was
never brought up ever again. It felt like this was purely for
the documentary team and as such it felt quite off to many people.
By I would say the second year of their marriage, Een's demeanor
had evolved. She was initially always on the channel and was
clearly putting her best foot forward. Although Eileen was special
in being a willing, enthusiastic participant on the channel,
I don't think she truly realized that Julia's online success
was directly because of their relationship, was directly because
of her. Now, during the channel's peak, it wasn't because of
Julia's music or vlogs that people were subscribing and watching.
Basically, I would say that people weren't there for Julia. They
were there for Julia's age gap lesbian relationship. And therefore,
Eileen had to keep being a part of the content in order for the
views and money to keep coming in. And I don't think this was
something that Eileen had bet on. Over time, it became obvious
that Eileen was featuring not because she want uh so Eileen is
the Nick Wick of the relationship. Gotcha. No, I don't think
so. But because she was caught in she was caught in the weirdo
viewers. Wife rates my bikinis. Rating my wife's bikini. This
is literally
This is for pervert viewers. But her bottom line, oh my god,
was very clear from Julia's video titles. And my wife rates my
Halloween costumes
rating my wife's bikini lesbian couple. I'm feel I feel like
the YouTube algorithm is a is a feeder algorithm. What the why
why is
bikini video so much higher than than
Julia's [__] content? What is happening here? 700,000
views versus 76,000 views.
Eileen vlogging.
Nobody give a [__] about that little twink. They
want the hog thumbnail. These videos all garnered the They want
the whole damn hog. Most views for Julia, but also put Eileen
in some compromising positions. Viewers began to quickly notice
that Eileen was always at home. She was always looking at her
phone or computer during vlogs. And eventually she quite literally
stopped going on travel vlogs and holidays with Julia alltogether.
Oh, I know a lot of you are going to ask about my wife. Is my
wife here with me? And I'm going to be completely honest with
you. I'm probably oversharing, but I I'm just going to tell you
what's up. She was supposed to be here. It's going to be a really
cool trip cuz it's going to be Costa Rica, Panama, Brazil, Canada,
and then back to the UK. So, Eing wasn't going to come to Costa
Rica anyway because of the adventure stuff cuz we're going to
have to be walking and doing like very like physical things,
dude. What is the Yeah, that's brutal.
It's not the physical things. I'm going to be real. You probably
had her in the first half, but then you told her that you all
are going to be in Canada and she probably just
I'm not on Twitch self. Thank you. and she's not into that and
she also has like a frozen shoulder and a knee injury. So, that
wasn't going to work. But she was supposed to meet me in Brazil
after here. She had a plane ticket and everything.
But then she decided not to go anymore because of the pandemic
and because she didn't want someone else that wasn't her or me
to look after our pets
are out traveling. Oh, she's obese. She's like high risk of getting
CO. What are you What are you doing? Trying to get her fat wife
killed off. Yeah. Why would you go to Brazil?
Obviously. Obvious.
No boy. Together. And I understand her reasons. They are both
very valid and responsible reasons. But of course, I was very
upset because we had this all planned and everything. And maybe
it's like oversharing to tell you this, but yeah, I was upset
and we had a little bit of an argument about it, but everything
is okay now. We kind of like agreed to disagree because I personally
think it's okay to travel as long as you're responsible about
it. Like I'm triple vaxed. I am getting tested every time. You
know, I I also think that's more or less the reason, right? She's
just fat and old and doesn't want to travel during co like that's
just all of it, right? Mhm. M that's got to be everything you
need before getting on the plane. And more than that, I get tested
very often. And I wear a mask. I think that although I'm traveling,
I'm trying to be very responsible about it. But she thinks it's
better just not to travel at all, which is also a valid opinion.
It's okay to not agree with people you love sometimes. So yeah,
that's what's happening. She's not coming anymore.
I was very upset. Julia's brand is very much, as I said, about
oversharing. But being in close proximity to the source of her
problems and also having based her brand on how positive, wonderful,
and happy age gap love can be, she couldn't actually share anything
of what was really going on without losing credibility. And the
thing she relied on more than anything, which is, as I said,
validation, but people could read between the lines. I really
hope she finds somebody that's equal to her in zest for life,
motivation, love of travel, and energy to experience what this
world has to offer. I wanted to make a comment about Eileen.
I think she was never going to come to Brazil. It seems to me
that she got the ticket just to show you how much she wanted
to go. Otherwise, if she already believed that it's not safe
to travel, why would she buy it in the first place? Please don't
fall for her manipulation. Your feelings are valid. I know I
don't know you or your relationship. It's just the feeling I
get by watching your interactions. During Julia and Eileen's
whole relationship, it was very interesting that Julia's channel
wasn't growing in the way that it initially had. In the past
3 years, she's only gained 4,000 subscribers, which is odd.
That is very for someone of her size who uploads sometimes up
to three times a week. I would argue that the main reason for
her lack of growth and low views was because of how this age
gap relationship was manifesting and how it was being presented.
The happy positive vibes exterior didn't add up to what spruce.
You good buddy? Are you you need some time off from the chat?
Is that what you're looking for? You looking for some a way to
get out? Looking for your way out? viewers were seeing. For instance,
Julia entered a beauty pageant. And typically when you do these
kinds of things, traveling far away to compete, you have your
significant other around to support you. You have your family
with you. But there was this really, I say, quite sad moment
during the pageant vlog where some subscribers recognized Julia
sitting all alone and they asked her where Eileen was. Where's
Eileene? Eileen.
She's at home. She was supposed to come with me, but she wasn't.
But then she, well, she said she's not really into pageantss.
And then she said, "Take a friend." And I was like, "Okay." And
then my friend, look, it's Sher's
missed the bus, so I'm alone. Now, although this clearly was
not nice of Eileen, there is definitely a theme when it comes
to the older people in Julia's life. Her mother even said in
a Q&A that Sherry, what do you think of the new Avatar? What
do you think of the new avatar here? Kind of liking it. think
it's pretty good. I like it. It's actually pretty cool. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you to Tom Bronson. Uh well, I mean, we
we could just get really demanding of this guy when he makes
free things like avatars for us or we could just appreciate what
we get in the moment and, you know, move forward and be happy.
No, he's already working on mine. It's actually really cool.
Okay, well, that's also possible. That Julia is quite insistent
on traveling and going out. Hardly even has to put on the Kermit
voice. Shut the up, Ella. You 9999. Who's ever heard of you?
I've never even seen you type in here before. You And this is
one thing about her. Oh, now I am super super super curious about
this one. This is the one. Wait, is this your mom? This is her
mom. I was looking forward to the most. What would you change
about Julia and why?
Thank you. Thank you.
Mom, you're just like my wife.
This insistent nature of Julia's definitely does come across
and how she features her relationships on her channel, even when
you can clearly see that the person doesn't want to be there
or is camera shy. Let's say bye to Eene. Eing went back to bed
because we actually went to sleep very late yesterday because
we were watching Netflix until late.
Let me just say bye to her. Look at her. So cute. Bye baby. Bye
baby. Love you baby. I love you baby. Be careful right baby.
Why do women ask
would you love me if I was a worm? It' be would you love me if
I was this size?
That's a tough one. Not saying there's like you can't come back
from this or something. I'm not like that much of a hater, but
like that's rough. Please be
She's snoring. Bless her.
That's sleeping right now. Is doing the dirty work for me. Oh,
come on, Tom. No, don't let me. Good morning, baby. Hi,
oh, hi, baby. Oh. Oh, Beverly, stop. And I do think there was
an element of this in Eileen not wanting to travel as much. She
was in her late60s. She had knee problems and health issues.
She was more of a homebody. And the influence lifestyle is a
lot out of nowhere. It's the lack of iron. That's why you can't
go out and do stuff. Okay. Yeah. She she got no iron, Jerry.
None at all. And the influencer lifestyle for Julia was a lot
because that lifestyle demands that you travel and get in debt.
Basically, after Julia bailed Eileen out of jail, nobody realized
how much debt she was actually in. Tragically, her grandfather
passed away and she couldn't afford to travel back home to Brazil
for the funeral. And at the time, she blamed herself. It was
because she wasn't smart with money and hadn't saved. And I can't
even be there with my family.
That's up when your cry sounds like that's crazy. I told you
she makes more money, but she spends more money. Yeah,
because I'm such a dumbass and I don't have any savings. And
she's not that much of a dumbass. She knows that she's got this
kind of hair, a little bit of a channel, and she cries about
not being able to make it to a funeral. That funeral is going
to get paid for. That funeral plane ticket's going to get paid
for automatic. Yeah, I don't have enough to to buy a ticket,
go to Brazil cuz they're super expensive and I feel so stupid.
But it was actually because she'd spent thousands on Een's legal
costs. Now, I do think there's a bit more nuance to this. Julia
had been making a lot of money since meeting Eileen, and she
self admittedly had wanted a big public fairy tale wedding, even
though Eileen hadn't. Julia also wanted to go on pre-wedding
travel trips and a nice honeymoon, all of which she paid for
herself. And being an influencer also means you travel and document
those travels. And so I think Julia, unbeknownst to herself,
found herself in a bit of a bind. She was married to a woman
with no income. Her income depended on this woman. Julia's income
was going toward paying for the financial problems that this
woman brought into the marriage. And Julia was under pressure
to keep up with the influencer lifestyle to jet and spend her
income in order to make income. Let's just say the Bachelor effect
soon wore off. Oh my god. Seems like we might have a problem
here. After an amazing but also hectic trip, I'm back in London
with the love of my life.
I'm so glad you're back, baby. Oh, God. Oh, God. I missed you.
Now, during these three years, Julia was very influencer coded
in not letting on that anything was wrong. And I do think this
also had to do with the fact that she was such a public and outspoken
advocate of age gap relationships. To acknowledge that her age
gap marriage wasn't going well would have completely undermined
the credibility of her entire branding. But regardless of what
Julia said, it was very clear that her viewers were turning off
Eileen. They thought the relationship was toxic. And how's it
going? We're falling away from Eileene. Uh pretty good. We're
watching some Tik Tok or I guess YouTube slop. Like some actual
slop. Basically, this woman made a channel out of dating older
women. This like I don't know, alt like goth type influencer.
Started like like married a 60-year-old, 65year-old.
Yeah. Yeah. We're uh we're just going through this video. We
made it an hour in. It's got another about halfway through right
now. Just another kidology autistically dissecting someone's
life like autistic alien like Yes. moment. Okay. But it is it
is worse than what ASOC's saying cuz she this is a 24 year old
girl that married this 62y old
This woman
she doesn't have money. She's broke. Yeah, she's also She's broke
and they flew back to America together. The old woman got arrested
immediately for stealing cars and then the the YouTube influence
had to pay for all of her legal bills and they're in debt now.
What? So, it's it's pretty crazy.
Yeah, it's pretty nuts. But she's like really addicted to the
attention that she gets for having like this insane age gap relationship.
Yep. Yep. So, we're just going through it. We're looking at uh
they they started doing like really weird like lesbian content
together. Really weird really weird lesbian content together.
Swaggers. Join the Discord. Uh yeah, yeah, yeah, we got it. So
they started doing that content together and then for some reason
when it's the fat woman, the fat old woman doing bikinis, 700,000
views. When it's this girl doing bikinis, 70,000 views. How is
the fat old woman 10xing the views? It's very confusing. Well,
it's a unique selling point. It's like there's no one else doing
it.
I guess so. Where where are the other, you know, 24y old girls
in lesbian relationships with 60-year-old women? Where where
is that? Where are you getting that other than here? Yeah, there's
a specific fetish or niche specific interest
person doing it. No, but this young girl, so she has two videos.
One of them is my girlfriend rates my Halloween costumes and
she's like in the thumbnail she's dressed up in two different
costumes or whatever. Uh it's like a nice thumbnail. That video
70K the two of them she's like I rate my girlfriend's bikinis.
The fat one is in the bikini. It's obviously just one bikini
picture. That's all that you can fit in the thumbnail. That video
has almost 800,000 views. Like on her own channel, her girlfriend
being half naked, it sells more than her. That's got to be a
mind too when you're like, imagine if she got into this relationship
cuz she just needs to be the hot one. And then the fat old woman
you marry gets way more views than you in a bikini.
It's ingenuous. Overexaggerated
and overshared displays of love felt. Whilst her audience was
expressing how concerned they were, Julia dismissed this as either
being hate or people speculating into what they didn't know.
Now, cracks inevitably did begin to show in very obvious ways.
Come on.
Hold it. Hold it. Come on.
Anna, stop texting them. There was one video where Julia decided
to cut her wedding dress. God, why? Why did I do this? Obviously,
it went a bit pear-shaped. And whilst Julia is crying and in
clear distress, Eileen calls to console her on the phone from
the other room. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's obvious. Yeah. Hi, sorry
buddy. Um, what about doing something where you're at this video?
Why are you calling me instead of coming in the room? Oh, I don't
know. I just thought it's okay cuz of because of the lights.
Yeah. Yeah. Can I just tell you what I was going to say? Okay.
But I think it's worth seeing, you know, going to to a professional.
Oh, I really it up. Oh, darling. It's okay. I mean, it's it's
okay. It's just, you know, in the end of the day, it's just a
dress. You know what I mean? No, it's special. I messed it up.
I thought it was going to be okay, but could it just really gross
like uh freaky like totally Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, they both seem
like this. This girl seems mentally stunted and then just a typical
She does mentally
something. She's supposed to be a sugar baby and she's really
happy at basically failing at being a sugar baby. Yeah, she's
like the only person in the world to be a breadwinning sugar
baby. Uh yeah, very unsettling vibes from this whole situation,
dude. Um this the young girl goes for like dental surgery. She's
like loopy from her dental surgery and the old woman didn't go
with her, didn't take her there, didn't bring her back home.
And this girl walked home. Apparently, it was like multiple hours.
She's walking for like 3 hours. She's like, "We're not quite
there yet, guys. We still got quite a ways to go." While she's
like high and staring at these random lights on the street. There's
like a light show on the street and she's like spinning around
looking at this stuff. Seems like a person who could be happy
almost anywhere.
And she is. She looks and acts like Mama JF kind of. No, she
doesn't look act like Mama JF. It's not quite like that. She's
obviously started her own channel and she does like her own music
and stuff. She's not she's not actually like I understand that
she seems that way to you guys, but she has like Okay. Okay.
Calm down. There's such a thing as being functionally related.
Okay. But this is different. This is I think this is different.
Well, let me pull a music video cuz she like what is this 7 years
ago? Hey sweeties. Welcome to the making of my latest No, not
that one. This one. See if she sounds
I need you to stop playing me people's YouTube music.
What's wrong with it?
Julia Zelg Twisted official music video.
Oh god, the glass the the
contact. Jesus. The vibe I get from this is not that she got
this cake just so that her partner could eat the whole thing.
Like, that's not the vibe I get. Doesn't this undo the vibe?
Like, you're trying to go for like this crazy goth alt girl vibe,
but you have like a 65year-old wife. I feel like it undo a lot
of what you're doing with the vibe. I didn't say it was good
music.
Wasn't this from before?
Yeah. Seven years ago. Oh, true. 7 years ago. Okay. And it was
2022 they met, I think. Yeah, true. No, no, no. It wasn't. It
wasn't. It wasn't. No, seven years ago. Seven years ago is like
right before co they they might have known each other there.
Oh, yeah. Okay, that's pretty close. Sure. Eileen, hearing her
crying and not coming into the room is wild. This is going to
be one of the meanest sounding things I've ever said. Wait, any
of these people watching her is wild. That's not even true. you.
For all you guys know, Eileen just doesn't want to be in the
channel. Is it not her right to be like, "Oh, she's crying and
then if I go in there, I'm going to be in the video. I don't
want to be in the video." I don't think that's like the craziest
thing. She said on the phone like, "Oh, you're not coming in
because of all the lights. I imagine that the way that she sets
stuff up so she can film makes it hard for the fat one to even
get in there. There's not a lot of space. Jesus Christ." Yeah.
But your YouTube would be doing better if you weren't in that
relationship. And that's not even some strong opinion of mine,
but based on the comments and reactions over the years, there
was also the infamous hairgake situation, uh, this video was
a perfect example of everything off in this relationship and
why so many people thought that Julia and Eileen were acting.
Of course, they loved each other and there was absolutely no
acting there, but it was becoming obvious that at least to an
extent, a facade was being put on. The camera is rolling, but
the tension is rising. The video starts off with Julia telling
us that Eileen is going to dye her hair red. And initially Eileen
is okay with this, but this quickly turns into that Daria episode
where Jane kindly coerces Daria into dying her hair because apparently
it's so easy. Julia keeps smiling throughout, but Eileen gets
really, really upset because dying Julia's hair is too much work.
Oh god, get this everywhere done. I mean, really, can I just
do one side and you do them? Well, I mean you I think you take
for granted how easy it might be for you, but it's just not a
natural thing when you're getting on my arm. Darling, I'm sorry.
I'm not a hair person. This is a nightmare to tell you the truth.
Look at that.
But this is
darling. I'm sorry. Oh my god. Why are you putting so much dye
on it? I don't know. I don't know what I'm
And you know Oh.
[__] Oh my god. I move and I get more. homework.
This was a disaster. I'm sorry. I'm really sorry, but I didn't
know what I was signing up for. I'm
Like I said, my hair's down to here. I put it in like it's shampoo
and then I rub it all throughout my hair. Mhm. And it works,
you know. I mean, generally speaking, it works. I mean, you can
try to do that if you want, but not with long hair. I mean, your
hair is like five times longer than mine. It's a lot of work,
you know. know I did this like to part just put the just put
the dye in the hair little bro can you you don't even do a job
job that she had to do in a month like so much work it's so much
work I didn't help you with a video oh don't be upset are you
actually No I'm really upset it's a lot of work and it's like
you know I could never have known what what it would be like
No don't be upset it's just funny okay
but no I feel like like look at you a mess like and you're not
usually a mess I say I'll survive. You know what I mean? I mean,
don't be upset. It's okay. It's not a big deal. I'm just hair.
No, but it's it's very stressful on me is is what I'm what I'm
thinking. Oh, you?
No, I mean it's I don't like making a mess of you and I'm very
stressed out by how much work it is cuz it is a lot of work and
it's late at night and I didn't know it was going to be like
this. I mean, okay, you know what? That's so [__]
real. No, that's real. Having work is really stressful. It's
late at night and it's just so much work and it's late at night
and I don't even know what we're doing here. I've never done
it before. Oh my god, my hands are sore. These gloves aren't
the right size. I've never done this before. I'm not doing the
layering as you can see. I'm It's okay. Just go for whatever
makes you happy. I'm just getting everywhere. You don't have
to do the whole length with the the brush if you don't want to.
It's easier to just do it with your paws. Well, I'm trying. Yeah.
Okay. You say it's easier. I'm not really sure, but don't worry,
baby. It's okay. It's no big deal. Well,
Dude, I feel like I have to take it all back. There's no way
she's a dog in bed. If this is too much work. Yeah, the like
her fingers are What the is she doing anywhere else? God, you
really are.
She also doesn't like getting messy. You're so good naturatured
about things. I mean, you know, I'm getting over here, but I
mean, I I mean, I think I have reason a good reason. You know
what I mean? I had no idea it would be this complicated. Well,
that was a situation. I can see both sides. I can see it from
the perspective of Eileen, who didn't want to do it and felt
somewhat pressured into it. But I can also see it from the perspective
of Julia, who was trying to make money for them and saw it as
quite a I'd say quite a straightforward and unserious thing.
The tension is rising in this overly loveydovey age gap relationship.
I think things really came to a head on a live Q&A. This
was the first time in well over a year that Eene went on holiday
with Julia. And it would later be revealed that Julia had essentially
offered Eileene an ultimatum to go on holiday with her or else.
And let me just say I have never felt so oh my god they're dating.
They're married. They are married at this point. comfortable
watching two people aware that they're alive and therefore being
overly loveydovey and smiley yet airing out their dirty laundry
and frustrations because it's getting it's getting a bit hard
to fake. If you could change something about your relationship,
what would it be? Oh. Oh, okay. You go first. No, you go first.
Oh, I don't want to be like offensive. That's okay. I like No,
go ahead. Go ahead. No, go ahead. That's what live streaming
is for. Okay. Yeah, I would make Eileen be a little bit more
responsible with money.
Yeah, cuz
Eileen can be a bit like compulsive. Compulsive
like credit and that kind of I hope they mean impulsive. Yeah.
Yeah. It's a thing that obviously I worry about her, but it's
something that affect both of us cuz we're married. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I could change one thing that would be Yeah. Yeah. it.
Yeah. Yeah. That's an important Sorry. Was that okay to say to
people? Yeah, sure. I I think it's a personal issue, but I don't
mind that you that you I mean, I didn't know what what else to
say in real life. And no, and I also think it's important to
be to be honest. Yeah. What would you change about me? Um well,
about our relationship really. Yeah. Yeah. That I wish I could
equal your vitality in terms of going out and doing stuff. A,
you know, but you seem to do pretty well. But you do great. I
mean, look at us. We spend the day at the beach. You're pretty
lively. You think so? Yeah, I think so.
Wow, you're so lively when we spent the day at the beach laying
in the sand. Wow. You're not I can get really annoyed by by things.
You know that, right? I don't get annoyed by you. I think you
get very annoyed by me. Oh, I do? Like, okay. Well, you want
to talk about the other thing? Cuz I'm messy. There's this creative
part of you that has a certain energy and and when you're a lot
of times you'll go through clothing and you literally will take
something off and just throw it over there and then you'll try
something else on throw it over there. So you end up making piles
of clothes, put it on the chair, not like on the floor. Oh no,
no, you're not like you're not like, you know, a pig. Julia,
does it odd use of phrasing? Said you that doesn't travel with
you much. Um,
it's okay. But it's different now. It's Yeah. Well, we're traveling
together right now. We're going to speak. Yay. What is the worst
thing your partner has done to you? I don't know. What was the
worst thing I've done to you? I guess she yelled at me. A
baby, I'm sorry. Yeah. But you're so like you're so lovely and
to like have made you mad enough to yell at me just broke my
heart, you know. Well, so I think my answer would be the same
cuz you you've yelled at me. Yes,
baby. Probably more than I'd be all at you. Absolutely crazy.
Nobody would have suspected this. Lesbians in a lesbian relationship
yelling at each other. By yelling, they mean throwing fists,
obviously. Okay. Have I really? Well, more than put my new avatar.
Oh, did I get I did get scented. Damn. Okay, one second. We're
going. We're moving. Probably. Yeah. Not Not that you yelled
much, but I'm less likely to yell. React. Yeah. Yeah. Well, that's
true. But I like wish you maybe experience. So when nobody's
buying into your seemingly perfect relationship, when things
aren't actually going well, but you're incredibly codependent
in your romantic and financial dynamic with one another, what
do you do? Well, you open up your messy and toxic relationship.
This is my beautiful wife, Eene, and we decided to open our marriage
a while ago. Now, I just want to put this into context. The reason
this went so viral across all social medias was because Julia
and Eileen had persistently been adamant, absolutely adamant
that their relationship was solid. It was amazing. It was fulfilling.
So this opening up of their relationship came as somewhat of
a shock. We were really struggling as a couple. Yeah. Yeah. It
was tough. We live in a small space. I was getting my master's
degree and working full-time all from home. And uh Eileen was
retired and uh that kind of like put a bit of a stresser
a major stressor and I I felt a bit alone. Yeah. Like I needed
more moral support because of that. I was always like pressure
on you. I think if she's retired and always home, what do you
mean? Oh, interesting to think about. Uh guys, we've got Oscar
the Grouch, Cherry the Grouch over here. Okay, let's go. Hold
on. There's that one. There's a There's that one. And then there's
another one where it's you further away, though. Like more like
the Kermit where it's like actually quite a bit further away,
but it is really good. Awesome. Let's go. Thank you very much,
Top Ronson, for another another fantastic avatar. This guy works
so fast. It's crazy. Okay. Uh amazing. Amazing.
Hold on. Let me try the other one. Let me see. Why do you have
to say like a Okay. Amazing.
I don't know. I'm bored. I'm not bored. I We I Here's what I'm
very excited for. Okay. I know at some point Eileen and Julia
break up. I'm waiting for Terry. That's what I'm waiting for.
Okay. I think for us what happened was our shortcomings at people
and as a couple were just exacerbated by the unnatural closeness.
I was trying to do all these things on my own and I struggle
with depression and anxiety. So, I was kind of like spiraling
down this depression thing. Okay, that's way too far away. You
know, try to un alive a couple of times, but also it wasn't fair
for me to put that much pressure on Een because she's 66 now.
She has the right to be retired. She doesn't have to live life
on the same pace as me because of the age difference. We are
at different stages of our lives. So, we kind of hit a breaking
point and uh we had to just make some changes to our relationship
so we could still be happy together. But one of the things that
we decided to do was to open our marriage. Yeah. Yeah. And that
allowed me to take the pressure off you. Um I'm no relationship
expert, but bringing other people into your failing relationship
is not healthy. Just in case anybody is wondering, being monogamous
and thinking that opening up your relationship will save your
monogous relationship by fulfilling needs and wants that you
aren't able to fulfill in that monogous relationship is not polyamory.
In fact, that whole gobbledegoop of a sentence that I just tried
to spill is a dumpster fire in contradiction. In my opinion,
these two were conflating their codependency for love at this
point. It was better to be dysfunctionally together than to be
functionally alone and single. Ethical non- monogamy is currently
trending across the rich world. Memoirs like Moore, a memoir
of open marriage and reality shows like Open House are taking
it mainstream in ways which I personally find very conflicting.
The vast majority of us are monogamous and yet monogamy is looking
more and more difficult to achieve with relationship. I don't
know why this had to be about I I don't need Kidy's whole spiel
against open relationships are dumb but I don't
No, she's kind of spitting. Uh Kidology has never led me astray
with her dating advice and her
uh and what in what world are open relationships mainstream?
Like what what sort of different planet you living on where open
relationship is mainstream or monogamy is like actually hard
to like yeah 99% of people monogous
open relationships like five weirdos that do that. No, I think
is on to something. She's tapped into the market. She Okay, she's
not wrong that like they don't work and like there's obviously
a huge dumpster fire around basically all iterations or all possible
ways of trying to do it. But I bros never been on Hinge. I think
you guys just don't care about the female perspective. Women,
how do you feel about that? Babka lives in like progressive US
cities and goes on. Yeah, her experience is completely uh in
normal like I say that's a different in like in like 90% of the
world 99% of the world 99% of people do not do open relationships
and would be disgusted by the prospect. I don't think 99% I think
the majority
vast vast majority. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. That's why I'm
being hyperbolic, obviously. But yeah, vast vast majority. Yeah.
Yeah, sure. I literally think it comes from being ideologically
pigeonhold to only be able to stomach hanging around in a small
handful of subreddits.
What? I don't understand what I don't I don't know what evil
Johnny Bravo just said. Uh Babka is chilling for Hinge right
now. Never ending cost of living crisis, which makes every day.
I don't know. Yeah. New York. Babushka posting. What is the best
state? New York. Are you going to say New York? I can't fix gig.
Oh, Cali.
Your biggest cities are covered in human
It's great. Great. Obviously the greatest state in America. I
don't know where Baptist coming from now. Her options are open
relationship or fent. So you literally border a state that's
way better. Oregon is a way better state. Okay. It's just infinitely
better in every way. Why would you say Why would you say Is that
where Portland is?
Yeah. Oregon. No, that state's trash, too. Oregon and Washington
are actually nice.
No, that the whole West Coast can get thrown out. That was an
experiment gone wrong. Okay. I just know Oregon is where all
the white supremacists went. So, I assumed it was nice. Am I
wrong on that? Are you sure? That's where all the crazy leftists
are. I Okay. Am I Am I insane? I'm not wrong. Right. Oregon like
the white supremacists were like, "This is where we'll build
our the white country for us." I could have sworn. I thought
that's where the um
Antifa
like Antifa on foot. We're going to That is Portland is not save
all the black people. Yeah, Portland is like that. I'm I'm obviously
talking about outside of Portland, though. Oh, okay. Oregon is
a weird place. You're all right. Okay. All right. Back to Kidy's
um thesis here on open relationship. Settle down into the pickup
fence American dream by their late 20s. It's no wonder we're
looking for and being sold new and exciting alternatives. Better
to be in an alternative relationship than to be alone forever.
And the reason I mention this mainstreaming of ethical non- monogamy
is because Julia and Eileen's announcement was the perfect pause.
Pause. I'm sorry. This just made me laugh. I see someone like,
"Lol, Oregon is not like that." And I'm like, who's defending
Oregon? It's extreme dad because he lives in Portland with Antifa.
The absolute perfect example of why people are non- monogamy
when oh doesn't Portland have like that has like all the crazy
drug policies right where they just like let everyone be explains
extreme dad so much. I get it. People are entering into these
relationships for the wrong reason is a slippery slope for most.
Importantly throughout the video Julia and Eileen conflated open
marriage and polyamory. Now, being in an open relationship means
you have a primary partner, but both parties can have other sexual
partners. It isn't about forming an emotion. Pausing again. What's
up? Mostly because she's not saying anything important right
now. Speaking of Oregon,
is that dude still streaming? Is he still on his subathon? Kid,
not kid. Cuz he's also from Oregon
though. I think he made rain or fixed his car or whatever the
thing was for. What? What did happen to Does kids still stream?
I feel like I haven't seen kids stream in forever,
but he used to stream a ton, so I wouldn't be shocked if he's
live right now. Look him up. Uh, I did, but my VPN is on, so
obviously Twitch won't load. Twitch going to be a complete piece
of He is
BB Poison. Am I saying Oregon? I think it's Oregon. Oregon. I
see on YouTube. I see YouTube. He is live on Twitch right now.
59 viewers. Let's go. I don't like this world to be honest. Shocking.
Okay. Attachment to your partners in as much as it is about having
with other people. Swinging is probably the best. Did Tommy C
do the Chud stuff? I don't know. Here's Queen. Here's our thoughts.
Okay. Why would you review Chud's review of Tommy C stuff where
he says he wins when you just know if you wait like a day, Tommy
C is going to review all of that and just blow it all? That's
my thoughts. Exactly. That's why we didn't cover it. It's just
like I'm not covering Ch's side of it anymore. I can't do the
Ch side and the Tommy side. I just have to wait for Tommy's response,
you know? I just have to watch the Tommy responses. Yeah. If
you're going to listen to one side, you got to listen to the
the smarter, more fact-based side, okay? And let them play the
game out of the water. Let the guy who really knows what's going
on talk about it, okay?
Also, I don't know if you knew this, but did you know that Chud's
dad is dead? He's such a loser. Yeah, I know.
Okay, just want to get that out of here. Okay, example. Just
on the other hand,
I All I'm saying is if Tren didn't want us to laugh at his stupid
dead dad, why did he tell us about it? Okay,
polyamory refers to having She looks like an [__]
on stream.
Multiple relationships that are not only but importantly emotional.
There isn't a primary relationship to go back to. Each relationship
holds emotional significance. And importantly, when it comes
to ethical non- monogamy, there's rules that are clearly defined.
And not abiding by those established rules is considered cheating
and is oftentimes why these relationship styles can become rather
a slippery slope if all parties involved aren't honest, open,
and healthy at all times. You can't fall in love when you're
in an open relationship. And yet separating emotions from is
difficult for most, especially when you're opening your relationship
in order to save.
Dude, it's such a bad angle. Your unfulfilling or failing monogous
relationship. And this is why I would say to laugh at a bad woman
in bed. Majority of people in the modern world. The conflating
of open relationships and polyamory is stark in Julia and Eileen's
coming out video. Do you think this is because the mainstream
has been the main culprit in spreading such misinformation about
polyamorous people and about open relationship? No, not at all.
If you like just laughing at fat people, that is like literally
the best content that's ever been produced for laughing at fat
people. I'm not even joking. They have been like there is a fat
woman who is like the most insane narcissist and they have just
been with her 24/7 for like the last week. I didn't even know
Fish Tank was live. Oh, that could be I think for sure. Yeah.
Yeah. No, seriously around for that for sure. Yeah, could be.
Be awesome.
Uh, it's actually good and I haven't liked the other seasons.
Okay, I'll I'll definitely think about it. Yeah, check out some
recaps.
Who was the black guy from last season? I don't say I didn't
like Bert. I know Bert's name. Of course I like Bert. Where was
dude? They have a Sam and Jet and the other production staff
just like they're with the fat girl and then they go into another
room and they just like Sam just turns someone goes is this too
exploitative? She might be worse than her. She might be worse
than Bert. Oh no. Oh well I'm so
Bert thought something was happening because he said the producers
like they want to him. I do remember that he was like making
deals with like the the CCTV or whatever the cameras and like
doing like this wink wink thing like he knows that they're trying
to him. I that's all I remember Brick clips from the first one.
The sorry I I didn't Well, that was Yeah, that was a third season
I think. But I I didn't really watch season 3 that much. Yeah,
I think so. I'm pretty sure what was season one at the end. I
didn't watch the end of season one. I didn't watch season 3.
I only watched the start of season one and season two. Sorry.
I made that you get lots of Bert updates.
This is season 3.
Jesus Christ. Bert is like a certified genius. Remember he is
been streaming reacting to the season as
Did you just see a bird running into the glass door? Did he not
see the frame?
He's just like he's just pretending to nap. Just walk it off.
You can't even keep walking. Okay. Nobody saw it. It's dark in
there. There's night vision camera. Obviously, it's dark. Nobody
saw it. You're fine. It's all going to be
It felt as if Julia wanted to open the relationship. That is
be primary partners with Eileen while simply having with other
people. But at the same time, the two were acknowledging that
Eileen couldn't fulfill Judia's emotional needs, which is not
what open relationships are about. That is what polyamorous relationships
are about. Also, and I mean no offense by this, but it was pretty
clear that Eileen was not seeing other people. And I only say
this not because of what we know of Eileen, but because of a
music video that Julia had released just before they announced
their open relationship. In July 2023, Julia had released a new
single and music video called Eat You Alive. The music video
is about a coven of fem sappic vampires who lure a mage. Oh,
dude. This is the thumbnail.
This hold on. This is the thumbnail I sent. Cherry. I was just
like, "Dude, what the is happening?"
The making of Eat You Alive music video behind the scenes.
Jesus Christ,
dude.
To their bedroom. And they proceed to um well, anyway, instead
of turning her into a vampire, Julia actually analyze Eileen
and eats her heart. I'm going to eat you alive.
There's a lot to read into this. What was interesting was Eileen's
response to seeing the music video for the first time. What's
important here is that Eileen claimed not to realize that in
the music video, Julia kissed other women. And this is Eileen's
live reaction to finding out.
Oh, you did kiss her. Oh, yeah. You weren't in
I forgot about that. Oh, I for I forgot you hadn't seen this.
You didn't know. I hadn't seen it at all. You can agree. Oh,
it hurt. Oh, you and you kissed that one, too. No, you didn't
tell me about this. Yes, I did. No, you did. You didn't tell
me that there was more than You didn't tell me there's more than
one that you kiss. Actually, not. No, you didn't. Really? Sorry.
I thought you did. No, I mean, I sent you the script. No, you
didn't. Yes, I did. You didn't send me the script. No, I swear
to God you didn't. Seriously? Yeah. And you didn't have it here.
I wrote the script. I didn't get the script. No. Oh, no. No.
I suppose cuz they're like half of me. I thought you were already
like bio. Yeah. Yeah. Right. Right. Well, I was about to say
I didn't see it laying around here, but it wouldn't cuz you have
it on. Yeah. I can't believe I didn't try. No, I didn't. I didn't
know anything about the shoot. Yeah. No, you really didn't.
The most important part. Yeah, I know. Sorry. Okay. Kology is
the only person having a great time right now. These are the
moments that make life worth living. That's all right, darling.
Don't you you all are thinking now poor Alicia didn't know you
were going to kiss the girls but she also kissed girl you wait
for it and you knew it cuz you wrote the script. I wrote the
script. Yes. This had also been an issue. I'll bet not as big
an issue in Julia's previous music video where she made out with
a woman and for some reason made a video of It's so funny how
happy Kology gets at other people's misery. And Missy Elliot,
could you really think of anything more psychopathic than enjoying
watching a streamer who gets joy out of other people's misery?
I can't think of anything that would be more psychopathic for
a chatter than to watch some streamer who enjoys other people's
misery. Anyway, I'll hit play. Eileen reacting to it where Eileen
seems a bit a bit takenback. My wife reacts to my music video.
Wow, it's very steamy.
Oh, sorry.
Wa. You look like you're really into
Sorry. It's kind of exciting in its way. I never thought I wanted
to see you with another woman.
I only bring this up because considering Eileen's response to
Julia kissing other women in acted out music videos, it is probably
indicative of how intensely monogous these two were. Eileen was
clearly jealous, and jealousy is a primary destroyer of ethically
non- monogous relationships. As I said, this video went completely
viral on Instagram and on Tik Tok, and its longer form on YouTube
generated the highest views Julia's channel has seen in some
time. Now, the internet's response was very, very negative. Basically,
Julia was accused of coercing Eileen into opening their marriage
because clearly Eileen wasn't seeing other people. Me and my
wife have an age gap and an open marriage. We've been married
for 4 and 1/2 years now and we are ethically nominous
and we're going to be answering the top questions about our open
marriage. So, another thing that people have been interested
in knowing is Dude, this looks like um what is this woman's name?
What is this? She looks like the actress. Oh, what is her name?
She's in as good as it gets. She's in uh The Water Boy. Why can't
I think of her name? Kathy Bates. She looks like Kathy Bates.
Oh, Kathy Bates lost a weight. She doesn't look like Kathy Bates
now. She looks like Kathy Bates at some point when she was at
her biggest. Crazy. Look, she Oh, never mind. It's a video. Well,
she kind of looks like Kathy Bates a little bit. I can see it.
Are we dating together or separately? We've been dating separately
for the moment because sometimes we're not attracted to the same
people because we are so different and we have different types.
So, we haven't been. But if the opportunity presented itself,
we would be open to it. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you know, of course,
that would probably be somebody's first thought. So, are you
looking for a third? But the thing is, I think what what what
compelled us to this period of exploration was
the quality of each of us turning like away from the other and
looking for something to complete. You know what I mean? And
also more like on an emotional level. To me, it's not too much
like of a like we're not asking for titilation.
Yeah. Yeah. We're not just doing this cuz we're horny. It's just
right. What we thought would be better for our relationship.
Yes. You're so cute. You're so shy. So, yeah. I'm blessing now.
So, we haven't dated together, but we've introduced Yeah. Yeah.
each other to people. Yeah. What's up? Yeah. Julia was also accused
of wanting to sleep around with other people whilst being a gold
digger. Both of them were accused of holding on to a marriage
that clearly wasn't working if Julia's emotional needs weren't
being met. Is it hard to watch? Um I mean it's not really hard
to watch. It's kind of funny. I I feel like this is what happens
when you get married because the content was fire. Okay. Marriage.
And I'd say that the most revealing thing to come out of this
entire controversy was that Julia's Reddit was they were already
on the ball. Basically, many people felt that Julia had only
come out with this announcement because she had already been
seeing someone else, courtesy of information provided by the
Reddit page. People were pretty much on Eileen's side or believed
that the two should break up because this relationship clearly
clearly wasn't working out. But as we know by now, Julia couldn't
handle the pressure and expectations of click baiting her content.
She had no boundaries. She was too emotionally invested. and
the comments were brutal and were clearly too much for her to
handle. And a week later, she released a bombshell video. Today,
I'm going to talk about things that I've wanted to talk about
for a very Oh, guys, we're opening a relationship. Actually,
no. I'm canceling my partner that person, but I never felt many
such cases. seems like because I never wanted to paint my wife
in a bad light, but now it got to a point where I just have to
talk about it and I just have to tell you what is going on because
people have such a completely wrong idea of what actually happened.
I fully gave myself and all my love to her. I really I really
did. I know I I made mistakes, but I have always tried to be
a good wife and I think I've been I think I've been a good wife
for her. In short, this video finally confirmed something that
Julia's audience pretty much already knew but never had a clear-cut
confirmation form. Julia was an unreliable narrator. Now, I think
there's a difference between two things. I think there's a difference
between a creator choosing. Wait, Queman, are you here? Hold
on. Let me check. You here right now? You got muted mic. I can't
tell if you're here or not. If you're here, I'm here. I'm here.
I'm here. You're aware Tommy C calls you beaker queen, right?
Yeah. Check it out. I don't Oh, nice.
Uh, that's awesome. Okay, there's good stuff. There's good stuff.
It's good stuff. Probably not tonight, though. We'll have to
wait for another night. Okay, it's pretty late. To keep their
peace and privacy by not sharing something and a creator choosing
to share something that isn't true in order to draw attention
away from what is actually going on. The formula is completely
and irrefutably valid. The latter can have dire consequences,
and we'll get back to this. Because Julia had no boundaries with
her audience, she couldn't tell them to respect her privacy.
Because she clickbaited most of her content, her credibility
was always in question. And because she created this branding
and narrative that everything was healthy, positive, and fulfilling
in her age gap relationship, her content felt somewhat disingenuous.
It sort of felt like she wasn't protecting her privacy in as
much as giving people. Well, you see, the other option, Queenman,
that we picked for you was Gonzo, and I pointed out that that's
clearly anti-semitic.
Like, but I don't know. Um, some other people just don't respect
or you know the the tropes and that have been used against them
over time. I guess I guess there's only so much around to it.
Lots of them. It's a real problem. I don't even know what that
word means. Oh, did you um the semi Don't answer that. Keep going.
Seeic languages. I was just going to ask if we watch the uh Did
you watch the full Tucker Carlson interview? No, I didn't. Yeah.
Um, it's pretty good. They get to Russia at the end. I can't
believe Ted Cruz didn't think like, hey, I'm like a total totally
bought and sold shill for Israel. Maybe he's got a country he
doesn't want to talk about. Took Ted Cruz like 2 hours to get
to that point. And as soon as he did, Tucker like totally melted
down. It was very funny. It's just that's why I literally I haven't
even watched it. Obviously, I said to people earlier, someone
in my chat was like, "Oh, uh, Taban based on some like that."
I was like, "Dude, if you don't think he's just chilling for
Russia cuz Russia supports her on, you're like completely like
I understand it was like a funny clip, but it is like totally
No, he points out like how obviously um Ted Cruz is just like
without without really justification or understanding is like
calling for this." And so he does it really well and like he
it doesn't matter what country he's attached to. He's just asking
the right questions, right? like he's doing a good job of pointing
out like, "No, you're just freaking out calling me an anti-semite
because you have no answer to my actual questions." He like does
a really good job, but then then at the end he does such a poor
job of like trying to show for Putin when Ted Cruz clearly hates
Putin. And it it just ruined the it ruined the first part a little
bit for me. It was too bad, dude. It was It was so funny that
like Ted Cruz was just getting obliterated on like Apac and a
bunch of other things. At some point, Ted Cruz Tucker goes like,
"I know how Apac works." Yeah. Like you you go find some Americans
who are sympathetic to Israel and you get them to donate. And
Ted Cruz goes, "No, no, no, no. That's not how it works at all,
Tucker. How it works is Apex sets up a fundraiser dinner for
you. They invite some people and then those people, like 50 people
maybe, write you a check for $1,000 and you get $50,000."
It's like, wait, that's literally exactly what Tucker just And
then and then as Ted kept getting pressured, he like eventually
is like, "It's just really curious how you're super obsessed
with Israel." I don't know. It's very very funny how like predictable
Ted Cruz is the whole time. It's like way better content than
I knew. I I didn't think it would be that funny. It's very good.
Like almost wall to- wall very good. You got to get through some
Ted Cruz yapping moments. He yaps kind of like Counterpoints
does. So the thing is I just Yeah, I just wasn't that motivated
to watch it cuz it's like who gives Ted Cruz to be honest. Like
I don't even think Trump goes for Ted Cruz. But yeah, I know.
But it's um it's like it it is actually contentious like for
a lot of the time. It's just like good content on its own. Like
watching um Yeah. Like even Twitch pole people who were that
contentious like the whole time would probably be good. Yeah.
It's way better than I thought it was. Yeah. I wasn't even going
to watch it. I was going to watch Steve insult at each other.
What is it? Tucker called him feline or something. It was a very
Yeah, feline cuz he was lying. What else, Sherry? What else?
I forget. Did was it did Ted call him Caddy? I don't remember.
I don't remember that one. There was the feline comment and then
Tucker got quite upset that he was called like a
was it calling him an isolationist? Yeah. Did not Tucker did
not like being called an anti-semite or an isolationist. And
yeah, they got into it over it. But who what? Dude, your name
is weird. What's up with the name here? I'm unfortunately going
to have to get you out of here. You need a name that's not that.
Good luck. What was the name? I don't know. Maybe you could take
a look at Kik and tell me if you can tell what the name was.
Anyway, sorry. We got to we got to continue on this video. Ammunition
to critique and speculate into her privacy. And what came out
in this video were pretty much a series of
guy's got to that guy's got he's got to find a name. He's got
to find a name that I can say in the chat. Bombshell revelations.
Julia and Alen hadn't opened up their marriage because they
up or find emotional bash ends. Get bash ends. You got to find
a different name, buddy. Okay. During times of stress, as they
claimed, they opened up their marriage to save it. You want to
try bash js? Bash js. That could fly. Bash ends. No. No. No.
No. Thank you. Wasn't actually a mature, well functioning, and
financially secure retired boomer. She was actually completely
broke and entirely dependent on credit and Julia for money. At
that time, we decided like that I was going to tried to equate
the nerdy kid that tried to shoot Trump as an Iranian assassin.
No, actually, BB Netanyahu did that. BB Netanyahu is the person
who said that. And then Ted just repeated it uncritically because
he's moronic. Well, no. Ted said that he misspoke. No, no, no.
Ted didn't say that. BB said that and then Ted said, "Oh, BB
just misspoke." Well, BB didn't really misspeak cuz now you're
sitting here, Ted, and saying that Iran has tried multiple times
to the president. Okay, that's you, Ted. That's you pay like
the bills and stuff and take care of us because like Eileen was
unemployed. But BB did say it. There's literally we read an article
that had the quote from us. She was also like letting me film
our relationship and post online which was also like helping
me financially cuz the channel did grow grow a lot at that time.
So I thought, you know, hold on. Oh, wrong. Uh, this is it. But
this is the clip. Play this clip here. I want to talk about the
nuclear threat. I want to talk about President Trump. You just
said u Iran tried to President Trump twice. Do you have intel
that the assassination attempts on President Trump were directly
from Iran through proxies? Yes. through uh through their intel.
Yes. So Brett Bearer clearly means there the two assassination
attempts that we saw during the campaign, right? That's obvious
the two assassination attempts that we know about on President
Trump and I don't know if BB just doesn't connect it and is saying
like other assassination attempts but he clearly says yeah those
ones like he's what yeah what you said
right there. What was the answer? What was the answer anyway?
It's probably miscommunication, but still it was like a partnership.
We're doing this together. Like it's
we both was fair at that time. And it was this had actually never
been
the nose. Now this is anti-semitic. This is anti-semitic. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. This was the nose for Beaker.
And then this is the nose for God. What happened? What are we
doing back there? What is going on?
This is crazy to do with this. This is crazy. This is what Cherry
requested, right? Cherry was like,
"Yes." Yes. The nose needs to be bigger. Okay. No, no, not Gonzo's
nose. Not Not Gonzo's nose.
You're talking about Xanderhol's cherry. Yeah, that was [__]
weird of her. Also, finally confirmed that Julia had gone into
crypto debt when
and she bailed Eileen out of jail. She pleaded with Eileen to
get a job to help get them through financially, but Eileen had
refused on the basis of her age. And the rumors about Eileen's
pretty shady financial history were pretty much confirmed by
Julia in this video after years of either ignoring comments about
it or dismissing concerns about the marriage as mere hate. After
Eileen was arrested on their honeymoon, what Julia found out
and went through financially definitely fits the definitions
of financial infidelity and financial abuse. However, it does
make Julia's role as an age gap advocate somewhat concerning.
A younger partner wouldn't have had the excuse of being retired
to not work in order to financially support the marriage and
their partner. Being retired and too old was definitely a running
theme of why Eileen couldn't travel with Julia, why she couldn't
take her to and from the hospital, why she couldn't work when
Julia got herself into debt for her. And this video was also
an indication of toxicity. Bringing your marital problems to
the internet in this way was not reassuring. She's still Excuse
me. To be fair, she was still in cars when she was like 35. Oh,
they just didn't catch her for 30 years. What the [__]
She left. She like left the country. She like ran. She like fled
when she had warrants out for her arrest. Oh, right. That's that's
the other reason why she didn't want to go on vacation. Yeah.
She didn't want to go back to the States. Although Julia tried
to reassure everyone that she was just clearing things up, that
she was sick and tired of being called a gold digger when she
was in fact the bread winner, it was no surprise when just 3
months after announcing the opening of their marriage, Julia
and Eileen came to the internet with some truly sad and of course
unexpected news. And have decided to file for divorce. You probably
already know why if you've been following us for the last few
months. Um, I posted a video talking all about our marital problems.
Julia's divorce was expected. It wasn't something that anybody
actually seemed to criticize her for. And in fact, her comment
section has never been so positive. I totally did not say we
were doing Oiler after, but now it's out there in the ether.
Okay. So, now possibly Oh, call after this. I mean, hey, people
are awake. If people are awake, if people are awake, we can go
watch some fish tank recaps. We can ham it up. I'm down. The
top comment. We're not upset. We're actually happy about this.
Now, just like the divorce was expected, so was the lack of responsibility
taken due to the infantilizing dynamic Julia had with Eileen.
Like, I know I failed in the relationship, and that's the problem.
Oh, I have to in many ways. I mean, I can't name any. And I realized
I fully own that it was me. You know what I mean? With the Taylor
Swift thing. It's me. It's me. I'm the problem. No, I mean, I
I should have walked away sooner. I should have instead of making
things unhealthy and that that's all me. What was unexpected
was how parasocial the whole divorce process was. Let's just
say Julia's divorce became an era in and of itself. There was
the divorce announcement video with the not at all parasocial
statement that Julia and Eileen had decided to tell us the audience
before officially starting divorce proceedings. Yeah, I'm going
to be divorced. We haven't started procedures or anything yet
cuz we wanted to talk to you first. Uh, I think a lot during
our troubles. I think I should have talked to you sooner than
I did. This is the first clip where Eileen's hair isn't died.
I don't think so. But it's I mean, she has been going out with
her for a while. It's not shocking because I think some people
were upset that I didn't because they were following us from
the beginning. There was the not at all parasocial series of
divorce update videos. As most of you know, me and my wife are
getting divorced and you have been sending me a lot of questions
about it. So today I'm going to be answering some of your divorce
related questions. Me and my wife have decided to get divorced
after 5 years of marriage. Oh, it feels like it's the end, doesn't
it? Sorry. No,
it's always like why we're still filming. It's still like that
day. And now that we turn on the camera, oh, oh, it's okay. My
baby. Oh, it's all right, darling. It's okay, darling. Oh, well,
don't give up on love. It's worth it. It's worth it. Even if
it ends like this, it's still worth it because it was the best
time ever. Really, really, really good. It was It was really
beautiful. Yeah. I'll always remember the extraordinary love
that we've had. Me and my wife are getting divorced, but we're
still co-parenting our pets, Julia and Eileen's love story. I'm
so happy to introduce you to my beautiful, beautiful
When your mother comforts you after the breakup. So, we are getting
matching tattoos today cuz we are med.
I am forever yours, my Eene. in this life and for all eternity.
I love you. Eileen is in freaking jail. Here's Eileen's mug shot.
There was then Eileen's response video to the divorce, which
was basically a Dr. Phil episode minus Dr. Phil. It was really
just yet another example of the three-way relationship that Julia
and Eileen had with their audience. I mean, I know people are
just going to go crazy with why would you pay a scent for her
to get out of prison when she didn't have any money and you're
spending, you know, you spent all this money, all your savings
on the wedding? Oh, of course I would because
I didn't want you to get beaten up. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The point
is, and I think you're too kind to say, is that you married somebody
with no resources. Do you know what I mean? And it's not No,
but that's not that's that's the thing that you get wrong. It's
not about the money or resources. Is you putting yourself and
us in that situation. That's what I'm saying. So, no. Yeah. But
you said you married someone without resources. It makes it sound
like, oh, it's because did Eileen signed a prenup? No. She could
probably go after the person. I don't think there's anything
like that. But I don't know how much money this uh Julia Zelda
person actually makes. Although maybe we'll see. There's more.
There are more arcs coming up. It was a problem because you didn't
have money for the ticket. That's not the problem. The problem
is I me not having the money for the situation that happened.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, I'm saying the same thing that we didn't I'm
saying we didn't have the money. Okay. You probably will disagree
with this, but that's how I remember it. I paid this credit card.
You didn't pay my credit. Yeah. What I remember is I at first
I paid for it when you first maxed it out. Yeah. You didn't pay.
But then, but then down the line, that's not true. You pay paying
me credit. I Yeah, I remember transferring money to that. No,
I don't know what you're talking about. You have not paid anything.
I did the first one. The first one I did. I'm sorry. I disagree
with you. I I have a real understanding of what I've used those
credit cards for. And there was, you know, you have had nothing
to I've got you copies of guitars. I remember you got guitars,
but that had nothing to do with you. I asked you if you could
get a part-time job just temporarily to help me pay it back.
and then you borrow money from our friends um and then you know
and then you pay that back you know which is already really unfair
you know what I mean and why I didn't act I don't know in part
it is because I haven't worked you know since I left America
really you know what I mean and I've meant to maybe go back to
technical writing and then I haven't you know I've just been
anyway and then then for you to ask me that December I think
it was could I get some kind of a job just like anything a clerk
you know I couldn't see myself going back to There was then the
official divorce song.
My wife's a an official divorce music
Um, can you pause this? Yeah. Can we bring up something unrelated?
Yeah. Why? Could you open up Twitter just because I can't I can't
hear my phone right now cuz I have these headphones on. Pull
up Twitter. Pull up VM's Twitter for me. Hey, it's VMe at Hey.
Oh, you guys don't see this yet, don't you? No, no, no. I have
I've not seen this and I really just need someone to explain.
What are those? Um,
Ethan Klein, this message is for you. Is this what we're talking
about here? Yeah. Whatever the [__] this is. This
guy is looking for a debate. Hey, Ethan Klein, this message is
for you. You think you can cancel on me? Think again. I challenge
you this Friday. Don't be
client. Okay, client like lion like Wizard of Oz. Just be there
at Stariller at Olivia at Dan at H3 podcast. Okay, let's watch
the video. I really hope it's not just the exact same text. Hey,
it's Anthony guys and this message is for Ethan Klein. Recently,
you invited me onto your show and I accepted, but then you made
up some lame excuse about having to meet last minute with some
of VMA. Literally just watched Better Call Saul like last week.
Billionaire was suing you for defamation and you was
Now, I'm not all that great of a debater. In fact, during my
last debate, I made this genocide denying farthead that you praised
on your show do this Palestinian faction. That's a popular faction
in the Middle East. There's a pretty decent argument that Wait,
stop. There's no way he's acting like he
in that showing. I think he's saying I'm not that great. Yeah,
he's saying pretty badly. I should just stick to scripted content.
But that I've also managed to get under the skin of every single
one of your sickopantic propagandizing
human colostomy bag foot soldiers.
So I think I can take you off. And you even said yourself. Now
Vim, I'll tell you this. I'm here with open palms, open mind
in honor of the friendship we once had. I would love for you
to call in at any time. Well then, anytime it is. Ethan or if
this doesn't happen tomorrow, Ethan Klein is a coward. Okay,
if this doesn't happen,
let more specifically this Friday. Hey, it's the versus Ethan
Klein.
Be there
or be a Dude, I'll be the first to admit I've never seen somebody
take such a pounding and turn around to make it actually not
the worst thing in the world. Okay, that's an incredible reversal
for Veem. That's a very funny video. It doesn't really help if
he just goes and gets absolutely sodomized by Ethan Klein, though.
So, hopefully he finds a way to get some sleep. Yeah, got good
enough rest. Okay, we're fully
No, I had no idea what this was. Okay, cool. Let's go, Veem.
Uh hopefully. Yeah, hopefully he does a better job. I don't know.
God, he's got a lot of watermelons here. Okay, we're back. We
got 20 minutes left in this video.
No credit card. You never wrote a check. You're the only thing
that
the behind the scenes footage from the official divorce music
video. Please. Please. I'm innocent. I'm innocent. I swear. Oh
my god. I'm innocent. There was then the infamous divorce party.
Get ready with me for my divorce party. First things first, let's
do some makeup. Look at my dress. We're at our divorce party.
Oh, they do the divorce party together. Uh, apparently. Yes.
Divorce party together. There's something about streamers. Whenever
they throw a party, it looks like the most depressed [__]
ever cuz they have this in like an actual room. They can light
like 10 people. Yeah. And they're all pointing their camera at
themselves.
It's just the most antisocial ever. It's always depressing.
3 2 1
And the punch. Oh my god. I can't believe I'm filming this. This
is going to be the most special video ever. I am here with the
most special person ever. I would like to introduce you to my
wonderful boyfriend, Keith. Hello. Let's go. What up, Keith?
Let's do it.
Oh, cuz why not?
Ah, because why not? Honestly, easily the best influencer ever.
Who needs LA influencers when you have Julia? Now, as I've already
said several times, according to Julia, the age gap was not the
reason for her divorce. She's still an advocate of age gap relationships,
and there is, in my opinion, a reason for this. Julia announced
her divorce in March 2024. By June 2024, the internet was introduced
to Keith. My name is Keith Wood. Beautiful name. Very simple.
I like it. It's a nicer name. Not birth name, too. But a lot
of history to it, is there? From the wood. It's from wood. Ancient
times. Wood. Okay. Keith got a new like maker.
He's ready for this. It's a very ancient name. Like wood. Yeah.
Like the wood. Like like the wood. Now, Julia had been seeing
Keith for I think the timeline is a bit iffy. Some say for a
few months, others say that she'd been seeing him for a year
or even longer than that. But regardless, Julia had been seeing
Keith for a while, but hadn't been open about it, which wouldn't
have been a problem at all, except for the fact that during this
time, she appeared in a Jubilee video titled Liberal Lesbians
versus Conservative Lesbians and was reportedly picked up by
her boyfriend after filming. And personally, I don't care. But
people were not happy about this at the time, especially as rumors
had already been circulating for quite a while that she was dating
a man while still being an advocate for not just age gap relationships,
but lesbian age gap and lesbian relationships. Now, remember
when I said that there's a difference between two things, between
an influencer keeping their PE. Is there anything that would
piss lesbian content consumers off more than finding out that
like one of the most popular lesbian influencers is actually
like that just I feel like I can't think of something that would
piss them off more. That's got to be it. Peace and privacy, but
not sharing something. And an influencer sharing something that
isn't true in order to draw attention away from what is actually
going on. Remember when I said that the former is completely
valid, but the latter can unfortunately have dire consequences
for the influencer? Well, the Keith era is a perfect example
of the latter. And why Julia right now is, I would say, quite
heavily disliked. Now, I just want to be very clear that Julia's
orientation and how it evolves is her business and it is completely
valid. She does not have to share that information with anybody.
I think the problem for her came when instead of keeping her
peace and what's that like she spe she specifically shares it
with everybody and makes it all of our business. Why is she like
protecting this woman's privacy? I have no idea. She instead
presented her new relationship with Keith as her exploring her
with men in the context of her open relationship with Eileen.
As would become clear, this wasn't actually the truth. She was
actually simply married to Eileen whilst being in an intimate
relationship with Keith. I should have walked away sooner and
I should have instead of making things unhealthy and that that's
on me. So although I cannot understand people being upset with
her for not being a lesbian, I can understand people being upset
with her for I wouldn't say maliciously, but I would say more
so rather half-hazardly telling them that she was exploring her
only to discover that she was in a serious committed relationship
with Keith. I would say that in the same way that Julia infantilizes
her partners, she does infantilize her audience. And this can
have dire consequences when out of the blue you introduce them
to your new boyfriend who you already live with. Keith's introduction
was very Julia coded. Today I'm here with my ex-wife
and my boyfriend. Yay. She um even referred to his grandchildren
as her step grandchildren. I have two grandchildren as well from
my daughter. I met them too. They're super cute. I was really
excited because I have step grandchildren now. You never thought
you'd say that, did you? No. Well, not so early in my life. Not
as you can imagine. The comments were overwhelmingly negative
and it was quite clear that Julia's core audience were turning.
She clearly took this personally. Remember, her audience has
always been very welcoming and supportive of her partners. So,
this response was new for her. After the backlash, she left a
pinned comment on the video saying, "I was effing miserable for
years. Now, I'm finally happy. Just let me be and stop being
so goddamn judgmental." Sorry. Listen, she was without a man
for years. Okay? Some may say those two are connected. Now, let
me judge. I think I Oh, boy. This represents a problem that at
least by now we are very much aware of when it comes to Julia's
old. For years, she ignored her audience's overwhelmingly well-intentioned
concerns about her relationship with Eileen, choosing to present
everything as a romantic fairy tale instead. People didn't buy
it. The views went down. And interestingly, her views only went
up again when she announced her marital problems and her divorce.
And even when she admitted that those who had initially warned
her about Eileen's shady financial past were right the whole
time, she dismissed them as haters. And there's a clear theme
here. Toxic, abusive, fake, happy age gap relationships are not
what people want to see beyond an occasional viral video. Getting
out of that toxicity, getting out of that abuse and that fake
happiness is what people want to see. Getting back into a committed
age gap relationship seemingly a few months after leaving one,
is not going to be received very well. and then proceeding to
dismiss your audience's concerns as hate or just being judgmental
is not going to generate a terribly positive response. Dear Julia,
I think that probably the reason some people think your new relationship
is not genuine might be because you used to pretend that your
relationship with Eileen was going well for years in front of
the camera, but then recently you confess that this marriage
has been toxic for all these years. Only time can prove that
this relationship will work or not. Give yourself and your relationship
time and ignore impolite comments. Don't even read them thoroughly.
Just be yourself behind and in front of the camera. That's just
my humble opinion. So, who is Keith? Welcome to my channel, sweetie.
He's like a male version of Eileen, but rich. Are you excited
to go to Japan? Can't wait. Him and Julia are clearly happy in
their arrangement.
At least she didn't [__] up the sugar baby thing
this time. Okay, this guy's got money. Yeah.
I hope this guy's got money. A beautiful young woman and he's
providing her. I mean, he's got enough money to know she needs
sign a prenup, right?
with a far less stressful quality of life. Today I am going to
show you to be honest that might just be what a really intelligent
uh scam artist knows to do. Right. I'm going make you sign a
print up. But you got to pay for us to go to Japan and then you
have to sign a print up and then I'll take care of you forever.
My dream closet. I've always dreamed of having a big Hannah Montana
walk-in closet and I never had one. This is my very first walk-in
closet and it's huge. There's a sofa in it. Like seriously. Notably,
he also at least seems to love to travel. And because he's very
wealthy, they actually go to pretty amazing places across the
globe. And the reason why I'm going to Vegas is because my partner
has a company and he's taking some of his employees on this trip,
which is a really nice thing. Historically, Julia,
dude, get me the Keith videos. I found some content for the next
while. I want all the Keith vlogs. I need them in my inbox. Generated
amazing views, but now the mood has clearly shifted. It's clear
that Julia's audience haven't gravitated to this relationship
in the same way as before. And I'd say that this is because of
two reasons. Firstly, I'd say that an age gap relationship between
an older man and a young woman is not as taboo or as shockworthy
as a lesbian or woman loving woman age gap relationship. In our
day and age, it definitely isn't as worthy of clickbait as a
lesbian woman loving woman age gap relationship. So, I think
Julia's found it quite difficult to integrate Keith into her
new content. Let's just say that Kulia is yet to have a Love
Don't Judge documentary filmed. And I'd say that secondly, Julia
is somewhat of an unreliable narrator of her own happiness and
joy. When she says that she's found her soulmate, that her relationships
are going well and that she's happy. Experience now shows that
this probably isn't the full story. And I'd actually add a third
point onto this. As we know, Julia is an advocate of age gap
relationships being founded on love and not transactional benefit.
And she's clearly trying to present her current relationship
as one founded on love as opposed to being some kind of financial.
Okay. I will say though, she out of all people, she might have
the only argument for like she has actually done the like anti-
gold digger thing. Okay, she she went and supported some like
old some old lady for like years. Okay, she did. Maybe she just
loves this guy. Maybe she just loves the way this the ball the
skin on his balls hangs. Okay.
Okay. But the fact that she's like 29, 30 years old and dressing
like this for that guy, she's basically just like bait like 26.
Like she's 26. She's giving him No, not 26. She was 24 when she
first met Ela. Eene, she was I think Eileen whatever. And so
she's like 30. You are correct. They were married for 5 years.
Yeah. Quick math. 2 plus two is four
minus one. That's three. Quick math. But yeah, so she's just
she's giving him the experience, right? She's disgusting. Hey,
she deser she deserves something nice. Okay, she put in a lot
of work. She deserves something nice. Like a walk-in closet.
Okay, she put in the work. The Hannah Montana walk-in closet.
Why did she say that? Just say you wanted a walk-in closet. Why
did you name drop experience? Hannah Montana.
Yeah.
Yeah. I didn't hear it. Now that Now that we think back, Jesus.
[__] Keith is living out his dream of 15year-old.
Yeah. Not good. Listen, he's got a he's got an older daughter.
He missed out on some step grandkids. Gross. Step grandkids.
We are going over their content. This needs to this needs to
be reviewed. Need to figure out what transactional arrangement.
And although I will take her at face value, at the same time,
she's perfectly happy to clickbait her relationship with Keith
as being a transactional one, referring to him as her sugar daddy.
Nonetheless, I do think that she was severely traumatized by
the financial abuse and infidelity she experienced. And because
finances were what ultimately doomed her relationship with Eileen,
I can definitely understand why the stability and the clear financial
security offered by Keith would contribute to him being this
sort of night and shining armor. Now, Julia took a small break
from the internet due to all the hate and negativity she was
receiving after announcing her relationship with Keith. You know,
like I have feelings, too. And it's it's difficult. Imagine if
for the last 10 years every single thing you do is scrutinized
and uh criticized so much. And this announcement was actually
very positively received. The negativity was also compounded
by her throwing a divorce party at Keith's house. That was interesting.
Eileen was invited and of course it does appear very mature and
I do commend them for doing this. But I think just based on everything
that everybody knew of their relationship and the toxicity of
it, it was a bit too much and seemed a bit a bit fake and forced
in a way. This is us doing the quiz. It's a simple thing, but
it was so much fun.
This is so
depressing.
I feel
and each to their own in this regard, of course. But I do think
that it became clear to Julia that a rebrand was needed. But
what that rebrand would be, we would very soon find out. Hello.
So, we got all dressed up and matching
because my baby organized a photo shoot to celebrate the engagement.
So, I said yes. I said yes. So, we're engaged now. way. Well,
congratulations
to a rebrand on your engagement. After taking a couple of much
needed and deserved months off, Julia would not only come back
with a new pog setup, but an engagement ring. I'm wearing the
ring now. That is a massive Hold on. That is a massive ring.
All I'm going to say is what? No, no, no. Hold on. Wait. This
one? Wait. Is that I guess an engagement bag? That's supposed
to be the wedding ring, right? Yeah. Yeah, I know. But wait,
why did Yeah, they're just wearing bands by the pool, right?
Okay. Yeah, that's like that is that is some crazy, isn't it?
That looks insane. Yeah, that is huge.
Was at like 10K months. All I'm going to say is I'm so glad that
she appears to be doing well and I sincerely hope that she has
a happy and healthy marriage.
Hi, my lovelies. I miss you so much because I didn't record a
video in like a week. Basically, Julia's story is one of how
terribly compromising and souling the influencer industry can
be. It is also a story about how terribly toxic putting your
personal and most cherished relationships on the internet for
money, fame, and inevitable scrutiny can be online. People are
going to judge you for everything. And although Julia's resilience
over the years has been commendable, I feel she's gotten herself
into a crushing bind. Currently, she's at odds with her core
fan base. Her channel hasn't grown for years, and her brand is
no longer clear. She recently changed her channel into a music
channel. Yet her music isn't the thing which her audience are
there for. Her podcast is in its infancy, but it is noteworthy
that the episodes which do the best are the ones. Whereas come
from what? Where do ideas come from? I feel like this is going
to be racist. I feel like this is going to be really racist.
I'm looking forward to whatever the answer is when you donate.
Eileen. Yep. She's still a character, which means that next season
is probably going to be very interesting and spicy. And like
I said, wait, Eileen's losing weight. What? Yep. He's still a
character, which means that next season is probably going to
be Eileen's losing weight. Let's go, Eileene. Very interesting
and spicy. And like I said at the beginning of this video, all
of this appears to be a bit too much for most people. I do wish
Julia all the best, but do let me know what you think. Do you
know Julia Zul? And what do you think of her content? What do
you think of age gap relationships and the influencers who advocate
for them among of course. Wow, what a video. Thank you. I think
that's it for us for the night, guys. I don't think I'm making
it for an oiler call. Yeah, it's really late. I'm sorry. It's
really late. All the calls will be coming when we aren't streaming
for 10 hours. Okay. I promise. I promise. I promise. This week
for sure. For sure. We were in the Discord before stream. Oh,
there was stuff in the the dude. We've been in Yeah, there was
stuff in the Discord before the stream, too. Chris Bett is doing
crazy. No, he was he was in the hospital, but he is doing some
crazy, but also what was going on. I'm going to be honest. I
like listened for a bit and I was like this sounds
Uh yeah, many such cases. What is MK doing? I have no idea. What
is MK doing? Everyone have a happy Junth.
Uh I'm going to raid Malik. Not not MK. Wish all of your black
friends a happy Junth. Okay guys, have a good night. We're headed
to bed. We're talking guys tomorrow. We'll be back. Going to
raid Malik. Have a good night. Go see Malik. Go say hi. Good
night everybody. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Good night.